hi can you guys see me it's pretty loud
hang on cowboy I'm not ready for this
not as ready as I thought I'd be I
always forget that the title screen
music is blasting let's try that howdy
partners how you doing thought I'd try a
new intro howdy
come here I don't know still too loud I
mean I always bring up [ __ ] again so
that I can hear him properly but how
y'all doing I think y'all doing that
there but tip of the hat to you could
shout to you 10 of 10 editing yeah I
know right yeah really Ben now well that
wait pan I got it
milady milady
oh you do know milady yeah pretty good
right yeah I'm trying a new thing trying
to embrace my southern side I mean my
dad's from Kentucky and I was born in
Ohio
so not really southern but uh howdy
nonetheless anyway so um we're gonna be
playing amnesia but not the main game
now don't get your hopes up
don't your panties in twister we're
gonna play the custom story Amadeus
we've actually got a bunch of custom
stories I was looking through I went to
mod DB calm which is a website I've
always gone to for uh those types of
things that I'm talking about right now
what am I talking about custom stories I
used to go there all the time for custom
stories and I wanted to go back and I
wanted to see if there were any custom
stories still being made because I
thought about amnesia and I was like man
I wonder I wonder if the community is
still thriving and it turns out
it is it is absolutely still thriving
this people still making amnesia custom
stories to this day like there was a new
there's one in my list I've got six
right here that are all highly rated and
one of them was released like within the
last month or maybe it was updated in
the last month but I don't know it's
still so loud sorry
I guess I could turn it down in-game was
going through my my my OBS settings here
yeah bear with me we're gonna there's
gonna be a slow start to this we're
gonna get into it if you're watching
this in the future in the VOD skip
people will comment when they I'll put
in the description when the video
actually starts just like this is not
don't look don't look my incredible
editing skills here but hang on
I guess I could just know there we go
there we go turn it back up once we
actually get into the game but for now
cacao cacao we're gonna be playing this
one so how are you doing okay so first
off first off Lamar Davis sup and rest
ease yay thank you so much for those
first offer stuff videos have been
inconsistent but I have a reason for
that if you don't give a [ __ ] about this
just skip right by this don't pay
attention to anything just skate right
on by but for right now the videos have
been inconsistent because I have been
working on these scripts for a lot of
things a lot of things um big projects
underway I just finished one of them
this morning and I've been working on
them for a long long time now and I
promised I wouldn't say anything about
the projects but if you were paying
attention to previous streams or whatnot
you will know that those things are
those things that I'm talking about I've
got three I've got three different
scripts that I need to write one of them
is like one of them I just finished this
morning which is a 19 page script the
other one's gonna be like a this gonna
be the small script it's not a anything
but the other one that I've been working
on for [ __ ] forever now is like it's
this it's it's I don't even know how
many pages gonna be at the end of it but
it's gonna be something in the range of
like 224 pages by the time I'm done with
it but been working on it real hard then
we're gonna onto real hard and I'm
really looking forward to what I can do
with it
so we're gonna get started here real
soon just as soon as everybody gets in
we are playing amnesia custom story by
the name of Amadeus Amadeus which is one
of the highest rated custom stories I've
seen in pretty much forever like I
haven't seen a I haven't seen a rated
custom story like this since um I don't
know I don't even remember one this one
was like locked in and a like a 9.5 so
we're gonna get started soon and videos
will become of that consistent to him
but I've been so I've been so happy
because it's it's so fun because I I was
writing these things because they're
part of bigger projects that I want to
make they're in the same vein as like
who kill markable
and date with markiplier like that scale
and scope but not like exactly that but
it's gonna pretty good I'll start
talking about it I'm not supposed to
start talking about it but I promised I
wouldn't start talking about but I'm
just so happy who think that I was just
I was working on it all yesterday and I
was like I should I haven't put up a
video today wait until tomorrow and then
I was writing this morning and then I
was like ah [ __ ] well time to do a
livestream so I can still talk to you
guys and get you guys excited about and
kind of just catch up in the meantime
other other news just like before we got
about four minutes before I'm actually
gonna get started here as people are
getting in but other news very important
other news about my life is generally
things are getting back to normal but
it's all gonna be thrown for a wrench
because on June 12th if you know III has
a fortnight tournament and if you guys
know me I'm not a I'm not a good
fortnight player I'm not even an average
fortnight player I'm a goddamn travesty
when it comes to playing fortnight and
some of you don't even give a [ __ ] about
fortnight and that's totally fine too
but for some reason I'm in the
tournament for some reason I'm in this
I'm in this for a night tournament
because they invited me and I have no
idea why they invited me but they
invited me and so I was like sure
because it's a charity tournament that's
the other important thing it's a charity
tournament so I look out for that III
June 12th look for me in the back
because I'm gonna bring a book because
I'm gonna die right away I know this and
then I'm just gonna be sitting around
reading like waiting for the next round
it's charged like I've got nothing else
to do so I'm just gonna be busting with
my thumbs up my ass so uh yeah alright
well it's gonna be great it's gonna be
pretty good
other than that though been working real
hard to get a lot of big projects a lot
of them not just one not just one big
project under way but a lot of big
projects underway which has been sapping
up my time but you know I couldn't
imagine a better way to spend my time
than doing that so I'm pretty I'm pretty
I'm pretty excited about it yeah but I
promised I wouldn't say this is still
way too early like it's only in the
planning phases we know I only just
finished the script for the first two
today so hopefully the first one the
smaller one will come out sometime this
month if everything goes right the first
one will come out this month and then
the next one will come out like next
month and then the bigger project will
be like that's like a that's a big thing
that I've been I don't want to do for a
long time but I'm okay anyway so you
guys ready you guys ready for a semi
amnesia you guys ready for some amnesia
whoo okay so this is a modest Amadeus is
a custom story from mod DB that I found
it was made just about December of last
year's when it first came out which is
so weird to think that people are still
making and needs to custom stories to
this day so if you guys are ready shout
it up in the in the chat I can't lock my
hat
Tanny how how do i how do i how do I
even do that I have no idea
let's see but thank you everybody so
much for being here
all right we're gonna go we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna go okay first
I got to turn up the sound the perfect
time the music just stopped so I can go
for it oh well thank you I forgot I had
notifications turned on for those things
oh thank you I appreciate that if that
gets too annoying
I'm gonna turn it off but uh thank you
everybody so much for giving through
super time you don't have to do that at
all really you absolutely don't have to
do that yeah and I'll try to read the
chats when I can but I'll be immersed in
the game here right here
we can up in a bed as usual I'm gonna
turn those off they they destroy the
ambience yeah can I pause okay I'm gonna
turn those off real quick sorry I I
don't want to like not acknowledge
people but the Obama ambience is
important and I'm sure that chicas face
doesn't doesn't ruin the experience for
all of you guys so this is actually the
first time that I played amnesia in a
couple years I the last time I did a
custom story for like a video was
probably 2014 or 2015
probably so if I don't remember how to
play right away just don't yell at me
because I'm gonna be trying my bestest
chair I can't pick I can't pick you up
what's even the point of life alright
anything in here nice shirts apparently
this one has like custom models custom
like monsters I mean it's got assets
from a machine for pigs all that good
stuff so I'm looking forward to see what
we got going on oh oh look at this look
at this I mean you cannot can I pick you
up know what's even the point all right
well I guess I'll just well I can't run
very fast either Sammy Sammy Sammy boy
Sammy girl
I don't know Sammy
any monsters in your closet Sammy Sammy
okay Oh Sammy Tammy Tammy no Tammy is
that your mother your other father Sammy
who is that
tell me more Tammy boy Sammy boy where
is it sha Shan Shan I can run now the
music's real stringy alright can I pick
this up now no still I want to throw it
in rage sorry what have I told you about
strangers are we is the volume good let
me know if the volume is good because I
never really know I really never really
know and I'm really no when it's live
I've been getting better at it but I
haven't been 100% I know I'm not
probably not supposed to check all these
I know my son is running off with a
stranger and I'm just here like well I
can't find my car keys
I'll just have no ding dam dong idea
where they could possibly be oh good
thing I lock all the doors inside my
house make sure Sammy doesn't get it oh
the front door god damn it dingus damn
it I would forget the front Sammy Sammy
boy Sammy Sammy boy Sammy where are you
audios a little loud okay all right well
it's supposed to because it's supposed
to be spooky anyway oh oh well a lot of
people are saying volume good I'd rather
err on the side of loud than the side of
ah ah ah twisted my ankle I think what
the hell happened
did someone blanca me on the noggin who
belong to me
oh hi Sammy Nikola Tesla is that you is
that my character from guns of Icarus Oh
went on stage he morphed into his alter
ego the amazing our Lewin it was a stage
name of his father and his father before
him the possibility that the line of
succession might end with corneas
himself was very concerning Sammy were
this dude am i Cornelius is Sammy
supposed to be the next one Sammy intro
screen
okay
oh hi hello have you seen my son I seem
to have slipped into this cage was
wondering if you could Amadeus
okie-dokie
I guess I'm in a cage now wait why do I
have wait am i Sami now bread shove that
in my gob
am i Sami why are there toys in here or
am i a big grown man I'm gonna assume
that I'm a big grown man and not Sammy
boy said it anybody seen Sammy Sammy
this looks great I mean there's a lot of
detail put into this one just to talk
about the game a little bit Sabbat you
and there Sammy Sammy boy Sammy Sammy
okay these are locked
Sammy anybody see my son he's about yay
high responds to Sammy but only if you
shout it like that anybody
maybe I'm a dolt Sammy I don't think it
works like that I don't think the whoa
Tesla Nikola mr. Tesla sorry sorry mr.
Tesla can you did he poof poof he just
pooped away oh well my footsteps who the
hell I always forget Oh mr. Tesla MIT
MIT oh I don't know he I don't know a
good name to shout at you
now whatever tezi Nick Nick boy oh all
right what am I looking for
poison bottle I should probably hurry up
because this guy probably knows where my
son is
hasn't kidnapped in some way or fashion
I don't know why you'd be leading me out
of this is so willy nilly maybe this
guy's Amadeus maybe he wants me to be
the new illusionist
Oh where's my son can you give me my son
back please really pretty please
hello hello hello buddy hey me show you
oh hello Sammy you in here Sammy hello
okay so I got a locked door there got
cabinets here I've got a big box no tiny
box in sight he's gone okay oh it's one
of the cranky Yankees destroy
this part requires your utmost attention
for timeliness of the essence the tether
that binds all living things with their
respective selves is called at the
silver Accord if you want to save your
brother you need to cut to the silver
recorder which he accesses this world
beware she is
wait well hang on wait hi boy
number one Oh number one I thought Sammy
was my son I don't call my brother Sammy
boy so I'm gonna I was just in my head
Ken and he's gonna be my son and we're
just gonna go with that and number two
what entity are we talking about also I
am gonna turn up the brightness just
give me two seconds on that one I forget
that I usually play this game with a
good bit more brightness involved okay
all right well cool all right
horrible entity some kind of familial
curse that I have to deal with for some
reason why me I don't know whose silver
cord do I have to cut do I have to cut
Sammy boy sir some somebody else
somebody somebody else
his father was an introverted man they
spent most hours of the day in his
secret cellar room working on his next
big trick with great determinism
determinism with great determinism you
sure that's all right word hello I
always have this Sammy Sammy Sammy boy
anybody you seen Sammy Sammy hmm Sammy
to be found Sammy wait Sammy just my
house Sammy
oh it's beautiful chapter one the man
behind the drapes as a man behind the
drapes
where are the drapes how am I gonna find
this man if there's no drapes oh yes
pretty it is real pretty Sammy Sammy
Sammy can I bling blong this piano Sammy
okay I guess oh it's like a ha ah it's
like a hubba bubba okay so we got the
library over there let me explore the
first area in here we got the study over
there we just came from over there
there's some big central looking thing
that leads to somewhere important over
there
sacred tomes goblets that are probably
very sacred to somebody grandfather
clock once it's tough always weird can I
knock that over damn it damn it hello
okay second I'm on the second floor what
do you mean second floor I'm already
there I would have got here special bugs
the sounds of go disco spell them hello
gift another evening of utter
embarrassment
yet another evening of half empty seats
my act is not compelled to the masses
like it once did the audience claps out
of sheer Corte see those claps are but a
painful reminder for a showman whose
ears still remember the deafening shear
of a crowd in awe the sheering meant for
coppers
but what really kept me going was to
look on their faces in this age of
reason the world is sensible
materialistic and solid to it's very
core but if you manage to fool them even
for a second then you can make them down
I haven't seen that look in quite some
time now seeing Abdel vanish into thin
air or a woman being sawn in half
there's nothing for them they've seen it
all so many times before and they are
keen on reminding me of this soon enough
vegetables will replace worse as the
main outlet for their disappointment I'm
sure to have the Crouch here again I
need to make them believe my performance
on stage to be real I am prepared to do
whatever it takes to make that happen
I refuse to fade into obscurity okay all
right well you know c'est la vie and all
that I'm pretty sure that's the
appropriate saying in this situation why
would why would vegetables turn into are
they gonna be throwing vegetables into
you because then you're problem solved
you don't need to actually get any more
money because they're giving you food is
that a real bird oh hello Sammy who are
you how are you are you a hawk are you
an eagle you Harry the hawk you Eddie
the Eagle I don't know and what's with
this lamp alright I'll leave you do it
you weird bird I'll come back to you
later then what we got over here just
it's another loop for this second floor
properly okay cool alright so what did
we get a key - we got a key to the for
yay leading to the study okay alright
let's go to the study
oh yeah oh yeah oh god I can't do any
speed tricks damn it they really locked
this place up tight okay so I got the
Saudi key but does that mean I need to
go to stay first maybe I to the library
okay I gotta study all right I guess I
know where I'm going
all right what do we got here none of
that no no no no we don't do the
supernatural giggles here
[Music]
yeah the introverted nature of his
family really took a toll on his mother
and made his seek appreciation elsewhere
Cornelius never really got to know him
he failed as a father no doubt but he
would always admire his passion I forget
that I have more time for good okay
[Music]
anybody giggle in here Sammy Sammy I got
a note I wrote down something Sammy look
do it in just a second Oh oops
all right well good thing I got a backup
Sammy Sammy Sammy anybody here
anybody seen Sammy this door open for a
reason Sammy there it is
that looks important okay cool now what
is this I don't know what I'm looking at
but let me look at my journal so I can
read that note notes no diary it's a
journal no mementos I need to search the
study for clues of what's going O Dubai
I'm an amnesia expert you don't need to
tell me how to do things I need to tell
me how to do things all right
was this magic box create light hello
how does it do oh no I have to open all
these what was that please tell me that
was just lightning and I doubt I highly
doubt that there's gonna be anything in
here but I just feel like being thorough
get out of my way I feel like being very
thorough you ready for a lot of flashes
mild preservation instincts on this hair
Lantern are gonna come strongly into
play hello anything there's gonna be a
whole lot of dick in here oh okay found
something that's good anything else in
here why don't do that okay I got this
it probably goes inside the projector
right and then I'm gonna be able to see
something right yeah all right oh well I
don't like duh I don't like what's going
on with his face or her eyes who dead
ain't good
this doesn't tell me anything this tells
me that they played weird games of poker
here or maybe some guy came along with a
knife and just like tried to get it in
between their fingers okay all right
good great glad I did that
why did I did that why why oh okay
well that didn't answer any questions
let's keep looking there's another door
over here maybe there's gonna be
something good yeah Oh tiny frog
Kuzco bird hello during the late 18th
century a mute six-year-old boy by the
name
Amadeus performed in Hungary Amadeus his
act consisted of him tapping out letters
on a board spelling out the names of
dead family members of the audience
sometimes full sentences that made sense
in the context what the crowd found most
fascinating was that Amadeus wasn't a
normal boy of flesh and blood he was an
automaton a machine if you will Amadeus
would be best described as a mechanical
medium the amount of credits given to
the automaton by the public amuses me
clearly credit is due to the creator of
this mechanical boy the Dutch watchmaker
Luke Van Doren what he managed to
achieve would make any modern clockwork
look primitive in comparison okay it is
said that Van Doren modeled the facial
features of his creation from a death
mask of his own son who he lost to
influenza at the age of six every night
for eight years
he worked to perfect his work in dim
candlelight to the extent that he went
blind
Van Doren became more and more detached
from society and passed away penniless
and alone the whereabouts of the
automaton remained unknown until just a
couple of weeks ago when it appeared at
an auction house located here in
Colorado Springs I put every last penny
I have up on this offer this mechanical
boy is the answer to my prayers this
remarkable machine will save my career
and assure my future welfare Tom tells
me someone wrong this ain't the right
time period for automata
oh well that's such a nice picture of a
lizard oh great
bird what are you doing here I'm gonna
call you bungalow the bird cuz I got
nothing clever to actually put in my
brain for this do you all heard that
right like the noise that came up behind
me as I heard that Sammy Sammy Sammy
Sammy Sammy anybody Sammy okay oh man
how big is this house goodness gracious
because when someone has a study it's
usually like I don't know a room maybe
two rooms
okay alright little suspicious about
that I don't think those are green I
don't think those are random occurrences
I think there's I think that's oh it's a
fire okay I think those have got to be
like scripted events so it's got to be
something good
got another stencil I can look at more
creepy old people doing creepy weird
stuff in a room oh oh oh
viola or a stop right base whatever this
is
cello okay it's a little weird that it's
standing there on its own but so far not
the weirdest thing I've ever seen Sammy
this priceless violin will scoop out my
son / brother Sammy Sammy Sammy oh
that's a good save
Boyd's gone I'm sorry those now am i
doing it jumped into the piano by itself
I had nothing to do with it yeah me
Sammy oh okay
forgot that I needed oil in this game
I don't like this record I kind of
regret putting this one on okay hey
whose favorite band is that raise your
hand in chat okay come on you can't get
me with that that didn't spook me at all
Sammy whose are you you can't give me
with a gust of wind huh yeah what do you
think you are man it's been so long
since I played this game that I I've
kind of forgotten just how like creepy
the bare-bones ambience of the game is
like the way the light works the way
that it makes shadows look devious the
way the sounds all work together it's no
boy no boy no at all I'm he's very boy
you know it's extremely Buena the
package from the Colorado Springs
auction house arrived this morning and I
am relieved to say the otamatone is now
in my possession I was of course very
eager to test its capabilities to
distinguish fact from folklore the
results were very pleasing yet in many
ways unnerving the Machine operates as
expected you ask it a question and it
saps out letters on a board
and forms an answer I started off by
asking it my mother's maiden name to my
amazement it caught it right except for
the spelling I never expected the
quality of the answers to be of such
disturbing precision and accuracy the
thought of this only being the symbiotic
rotation of cogs and sprockets really
baffles the mind although I must confess
a machine of this kind could make even
the most rational of Minds question
itself
as a magician and illusionist I've seen
and mastered the most cunning of tricks
but nothing comes even close to this
level of deception Luke Van Doren truly
was a genius girl local oh the whole
session was pandered with awe and Wonder
there was one instance that confused me
greatly shortly after I had finished
asking my questions
the otamatone started to move its hand
its bailout the word hungry does this
highlight a flaw in fenders engineering
for practical reasons this is what I
will assume any other tempting
explanation would be nonsensical this
afternoon I performed a hastily put
together act for my manager mr. Cameron
needless to say he was astounded he
immediately contacted the owner of the
longmont the finest theater in Colorado
and booked 12 shows first one being just
within a week things are finally taking
a turn for the better
oh I'm sure they are when a mechanical
child robot says it's hungry that's
definitely a good sign
[Music]
hello anybody okay I've got a few slides
this weird glowy plan here is probably a
vu probably a very very very none
importance right this is not it's not
essential Sammy are you in there is this
the silver thread I've heard so much
about no apparently not okay I've got
three slides let's go ahead and get out
of here let's get downstairs and take a
look at them have them be implanted in
my nightmares we're gonna pretend like
that never happened
we're just gonna skate on by as if
nothing happened you didn't hear
anything I didn't hear anything we
didn't hear nothing nothing happened
nothing happened
okay anyway let's take this okay this is
three oh wait I'm missing one okay this
is real you got something coming out of
your nose you guys I'm really coming out
of your nose okay that's three four okay
that's weird
oh it's like some magic trick or torture
or whatever it is okay so I need the
number two stencil which has got to be
on the way to the other ones because if
I got three and four that means I missed
number two on the way was it in here
somewhere
maybe Sammy I mean anybody you hiding
Sammy
you better not be it's gotta be I
thought it was meticulous about this but
apparently I wasn't
ME ME this is the part where I always
feel like an idiot because somehow I
managed to over look the tiniest
seemingly insignificant detail and it'll
be no good for anybody involved
okay back upstairs we go into the room
where we didn't actually hear a noise
because we definitely didn't okay I got
one in here so it must be downstairs
somewhere right that's the only thing
that makes sense cuz it couldn't have
been there were two up here one in that
chest and then one in the other room and
it's not like there was another room
that I missed right so it's got to be
it's gotta be downstairs somewhere
something incredibly mistaken which I
probably am I mean I haven't been moving
around with my light which is kind of
stupid on my part because definitely
have you guys seen it
hey you guys because you guys see it was
downstairs okay it's in a drawer okay
you guys you guys probably saw it and
wouldn't be wouldn't be leading me
astray because you'd never ever ever
ever
hmm hello No ah there it is it wasn't on
a drawer but it was on a shelf okay got
that I don't know if there's gonna
unlock something when I use this one
because it's probably the last one what
do we got what kind of surprise we're
looking for here
Oh though oh hey okay whoa boy saving
the best for last huh I didn't hear
anything nope I still don't hear nothing
weirdest thing I I've gone completely
deaf all of a sudden so bizarre huh
weird weird huh oh that wasn't close
before
where's it coming from is it coming from
the locked door
oh wait whoa
hello hi hello oh it is okay can I get a
peek okay all right oh yeah it seems
about right okay all right
that seems about right okay all right
cool great was it this is this is
nothing oh oh it's not nothing
well it's not nothing at all
two paths down into a cellar of some
sort great great great good Hey
I love the pacing of this custom story
by the way very good with the slow
buildup
please tell me that's oil and not some
kind of horrible bloody goop courtyard
an underground every man needs to look
into the Darksiders nature his father
said sternly that is where the passion
lies and trying to ignore it is an
exercise in futility I am conscious of
my obsession the same should apply to
you it was the closest they ever had to
a father and son talk is gonna be fun
oh it's not underground oh it's just an
underground tunnel that leads somehow to
a courtyard hello Sammy Sammy boy you're
a big Bros here apparently oh yeah how
you holding up Sammy boy
you're doing good great how much oil do
I have plenty okay my sanity's doing
great I'm doing great we're all doing
great ah down oh you know I want to go
down I've never wanted anything more in
my life than to go down there that's why
I'm just making sure I'm right
to go down why do those birds and why do
they sound so much like people screaming
see I don't like that very much that
doesn't that doesn't bode well for me
and makes me think that maybe going down
there's a bat Oh a maze Oh
well hurrah hurrah great thank you for
that thank you what did I tell you about
the ethereal children laughing I told
that I didn't want no part of that it's
not part of this experience okay I'll
take the howling I'll take the howling
the howling I will allow I swear if a
pair of twins pops out and say come play
with me I'm I'm done I'm done zone okay
all right boy I love mazes for I really
love mazes
[Music]
I can do that too
you're not so special
mmm sure is uh screaming in this mo
hello baby how are you doing
been a long time can I just say yeah
I'll just sploosh right in here just dip
my toes in if you don't mind okay anyway
how are you doing well we got here
anything special
nothing all right I'll be on my way you
take care of yourself huh maybe I'll
take care of you later okay I'm sorry
all right moving on nothing here what
was the point what's the point of all
this just to look nice I doubt that very
much I doubt that extremely just like I
doubt a lot of things is it the past
that came out of you wanna have a
screaming contest with me you want you
broad can't win against a crow but that
guy if you want have a screaming contest
we meet your duns oh you're done Yin
rings you're never gonna win never see
the light of day oh okay it's fine why
did that scare me so much that's
[ __ ] don't do that that wasn't scary
not even a little bit can I have a
little bit scary not scary at all in
fact yeah I was just trying to have that
screaming contest I was talking about
anyway
carrying on I'm burning through the oil
I don't really need it in this area but
it's for your benefit that I got the oil
Lantern on now okay all right
don't even try me
birds are fine they dress okay
what is this Lake up like a feasting
hall of some sort that people still have
feasting halls in these days oh look
where the musicians play where's your up
rail oh there they are
Oh what can i how can I touch these what
guys smash this one if I spangled this
with the other one all right there we go
and okay all right good enough where the
hell am I going it is used to be looping
around these landmarks I don't know why
maybe the landmarks are there for me to
remember because I'm gonna be running in
short order through this oh this is
lovely
oh wait that's the gate that oh I made
it through well good for me I'm good for
you good for all of us good for
everybody involved all right that was
that was cool man I really really love
the pace of this game this game Sammy
Sammy as are you tell me okay
Oh like this Sammy Sammy I don't like it
Tammi it ain't it ain't good I'm
probably gonna die of carbon monoxide
something tells me these old - I'm going
down there these old-timey
something got out something escaped oh
and then it's gonna eat me oh my
I've turned this off for do I have to
deal with the rumbling in my ear it's so
dark I need I shouldn't have used my
lantern so much over there okay all
right I kind of forgot that that's a
thing Oh ruff okay that's all we got and
or needed anything up here ain't jumping
puzzle of some sort okay then I will go
into the basement of death where I heard
the horrible monster roar at me is there
another no okay here we go
oh boy oh that's a noise oh those are
those are some good noises okay hang on
it is with a heavy hand I guide this pin
the grand opening of my new act was a
complete and utter disaster the
automaton is as unpredictable as the
Colorado weather there I stood like a
buffoon talking to a puppet with no
response whatsoever I have never been so
humiliated in my whole career tonight's
debacle might have rendered my career
unsalvageable I told Mr Cameron that we
must act fast before the word of my
failure spreads like an inextinguishable
wildfire luckily mr. Cameron with his
reputation on the line managed to
convince the owner of the theater to
give me one last chance the owner agreed
to let me perform at one of his less
prestigious theaters in a couple of
weeks
if the next show fails not even a
well-respected and established manager
like mr. Cameron will be able to save me
and he was keen on letting me know this
I must examine the automaton yeah okay
you're good okay all right maybe because
there's like the soul of a child trapped
in it and that's why you took Sammy Bo
I'm getting flashbacks do you guys
remember oh do you remember in the
original amnesia do you remember the
first time you go down into the basement
and you hadn't really seen a monster oh
oh that's not good
Sammy Sammy boy
I'll just take a nap then lay my head to
rest smooth beautiful okay they're gone
good great okay good thing five demon
children and don't think I didn't seem
to call it daesil up there at the top oh
boy that's not good
whispering probably is not the best okay
there's something back there can I get
back there not yet okay all right so is
there still a monster down here that I
should worry about probably or is
hatches like a that is not not my
concern at this juncture anything under
these sacks of potatoes no what was that
because there's something about the slow
slow build-up that just that just like
it creates it gets you jumping at
shadows and that's what I really love
about horror games the thick glass of
the Chinese water tank was taking too
long to break from a front row seat he
saw his father's face to a final jerky
movement before becoming a completely
okay all right I gotta be a little more
skedaddle II about that okay we're in
the kitchen now which is great until now
I haven't been able to write this entry
since I inspected the automaton a few
days ago the events that took place left
me puzzled and I have spent the last few
days trying to make sense of it but to
no avail it defies logic I have most
recently come to realize that logic and
reason can only get you so far this
entry will serve as a documentation of
the event as I experienced it
I brought the automaton to my father's
prop room with the intent to solve
whatever problem that occurred during my
disaster performance at the Longmont
Theater
I opened the hatch at the back of the
automaton and what I saw sent the chill
of my spine
some cogs were rusted and crooked beyond
repair and some had even fallen off
their position there is no way that the
condition of those cogs deteriorated so
drastically between the time of my
demonstration for Cameron and my
performance at the longmont there is
just no way suddenly I heard a faint
whisper and coming from the hatch I
questioned my census at first like any
reasonable man would but thank him
another still faint but yet audible
whisper it was a harsh guttural female
voice clearly said the word hungry I ran
out of the prop room as fast as I
possibly could I'm not returned there
since the fear that I must if I want to
save my career I'm going to lose the
estate that has been in my family for
centuries
I must gather the courage to enter that
room again okay whatever I mean just to
be fair I've been hearing voices and
whispers this whole goddamn time and
I've still been charging in blind and
screaming hello tell me Sonic Sammy
anybody Sammy oil oil Sammy
you here Oh statue okay alright this
seems lovely how big is this house by
the way like this guy's act must have
been successful if he has like an entire
spool sprawling mansion like this but
something tells me it's uh only brought
upon him by the sacrifice of people to
this otama toe oh that's a lovely
I don't like that at all no how about no
what are you gonna give a toast hmm
well that's peculiar something tells me
that maybe there aren't a bunch of
people jovially talking to each other in
here Oh congratulations winning bidder
this letter is to congratulate you on
winning the auction of the Hungarian
automaton we hope to see your
participation in future auctions
sincerely Colorado Springs auction house
thank you all right well glad we won
that I didn't know he won Oh an auction
as in he bit a bid on it and he spent
money and wanted why did that scare me I
don't know maybe I'm just a big old
[ __ ] baby why is there a bathroom why
is your bathroom so why is there a
bathtub right next to a dining room area
that doesn't make no sense all right
there's a dead body in the bathroom in
the main floor no oh no wow we stumble
across the dead by your look I got a
document is there is a dead body who the
police are really gonna be really gonna
need my notes for this how would they
have known if not I wrote it down
hello oh this is another sign halt hmm
okay before I go over there let me make
sure that everything's hunky duty over
here what's going on hello
another bathroom it's another oh it's
the kid i looped oh oh okay it's just a
big loop it's a big cycle okay so anyway
what about that dead body then what does
that matter is just go to the main entry
area
do it do oh I'm back okay well I haven't
found another key yet so there's got to
be something it's got to be here right
oh well this is nice there's lovely it's
beautiful even a key game without the oh
not hooker Raph seems to use wax
cylinders to play sounds the cylinder in
place plays nothing of importance I
picked up a lighter good okay so I need
to find a wax cylinder to play for this
for something not sure what okay but I
got a key what's this key to to the
library okay so the library is gonna be
my next step I've got a lighter which
means that I could probably light things
on fire if I wanted to like I could burn
this whole place down if I really want
to do are you happy that you Sammy Sammy
Sammy Sammy
well that one downstairs Sammy Sammy Oh
Sammy anybody seen Sammy Sammy Sammy
okay so nothing else up here that I need
eventually I'm gonna get wax cylinders
and probably come back here if I had to
guesstimate how this is gonna go down
but there's one more look I haven't left
yet to gather the courage to inspect the
automaton again oh you big [ __ ] baby in
fact I am more afraid to do so for every
passing day just get it over with and
I'm laying in my bed at night unable to
escape the thoughts in my head I hear
that whispering voice repeating over and
over again some nights I hear the
floorboards in the hollow a creak the
creakings are subtle and far apart as if
someone is slowly walking down the hall
towards my bedroom door I spend most
nights deprived of sleep staring at the
door handle expecting it to turn at any
moment
it never does but I can hear the
creaking lurking closer every night
alright that's good maybe you should go
inspect the automaton then maybe you
should do that huh
Zeo work set mark you should place
Salani Toby's three full game is out in
the complete campaign and multiplayer uh
I mean I guess if you guys really want a
full playthrough of Slendy Tubby's three
although I imagine it's probably a
horrifying experience the likes of which
I've never seen
okay sure this alright so there that's
probably just saying thirds off padlock
and thus in the dining area that's
probably that's probably important to
know so once I get a key for that
padlock I'll come back to that but I got
the key to the library which means that
I can all right
[Music]
okay probably I'm probably gonna assume
that I need that at some point but I
don't think I need creepy music blaring
in the main level any time soon probably
I don't know this is all just some sick
game to this guy so no no maybe I just
wanted to provide me with some music for
it and the library we go please play it
no I'm not gonna play it why would I
play that oh the passion news mother
fell in love with later became the very
thing that destroyed her eventually she
lost her courtesy and took the men home
his father probably had no idea and even
if he had he didn't seem to care I like
what you've done with the blades very
bright in here
sure hope you don't change that as I
like the light the light's real good
anyways booze for me huh for you okay
alright well this is just goddamn
delightful okay
pleasant music - don't know why see it's
moments like this when it gets too
Pleasant in here that I absolutely 100%
know that they're gonna remove it from
me they are gonna take this away from me
because I'm too comfortable and there's
no way that they could keep this up
astral projection is an out-of-body
experience that assumes the existence of
an astral body separate from the
physical body
astral progression projection denotes
the astral body leaving the physical
body to travel in an astral plane
the idea of astral travel is rooted in
common worldwide religious accounts of
the afterlife
it is frequently reported in association
with dreams and forms of meditation
patients have aborted feelings similar
to the descriptions of astral projection
induced through various Hallucigenia
hallucinogenic and hypnotic means there
is no evidence for the contention that
one can consciously leave the body and
make observations it tends to verify
these claims have consistently failed in
spite of the variety of claims to the
contrary okay that's good to know why
did I need to know that
baby why did I need to know that why was
that important to anything that I'm
doing here ooh nice map congratulations
nice hat - all right I've looked about
everywhere that I could possibly look
down here anyway and once again it's too
nice way way way too nice way too nice
you played mohandro said you played dark
wood a while back but the full version
is out now it's really good and it would
be awesome I did like dark wood I
remember that game it was a top-down
kind of like wasn't it randomly
generated in a way and like he was had
monsters but it wasn't really a top-down
shooter is more like a top-down
adventure RPG something like that I
would love to see the full version of
that people didn't request that a lot
like I think I did like two episodes or
two or three episode when I stopped
playing it I did that - so many game
someday your guys are gonna have to give
me a full running list of every single
game that I've started and not finished
some of them I have an excuse that I'm
like I didn't actually like it but some
of them I was like oh get back to that
and then I don't cuz you know how
valuable markiplier promises the silver
cord is mentioned by mystics and the
context of dying and astral projections
it is the tracer I need it is the tether
between your astral spirit and your
physical self it is said that the call
must remain connected during the astral
progression because if it breaks the
projector will die Hey okay I don't know
if that added any value to this but I've
got buttons and I'm damn well gonna use
I may I spend time making those what's
this all about
okay that doesn't sound good whatever
whatever it's doing like some kind of
timer thing it's like a time-release
who's here what's it okay
a week has passed since my last entry I
don't know the last time I slept dreams
and reality have mended together into an
undefiable liquid now I can't tell one
from the other as I'm in my bedroom
writing this I can hear a woman wailing
in pain from the darkness of the hallway
hmm the wailing is sometimes interrupted
by an unearthly cry as if to beckon me
like a siren from the sea she is begging
me to help her what if you just forgot
that it like he lived with his grandma
and his grandma's like on the floor
there's no life alert in this area uh
why don't you help me please
oh no the curse again shut up old lady
side please all right
that's sad and anyway we going on that
map again up there oh well back and grow
okay well let me think about what I'm
doing here
whoa it is uh there's various Bouton's
okay so if I push this one and then I
that that now oh there must be a third
one and I gotta push him in sequence or
something okay so I haven't found the
other one I thought it was pretty
thorough in this I've been pretty
thorough on this I can't believe that I
haven't been finding everything but if I
didn't find it I didn't find it so I
gotta go back I would imagine it's on
the bottom floor because if it's not in
here staying over there if it's not up
around here then it's probably going to
be on the bottom floor and that's why it
gives me so much time to run downstairs
hit it go back up and then hit the last
one because I'm all in about that
there's just three of them because that
would make sense to me nothing here
nothing here nothing there it's got to
be in one of these many many bookshelves
I didn't really inspect this one no baby
hey baby you know where are my can find
me a switch you got you know know where
I can find me like a big red bar ten
weight bar ten it's so obvious now
there's got to be something
I'm gonna be stuck here for a while
aren't I
yeah the piano is nice it's real nice
it's real nice
not a thing can't see nothing can't find
nothing
hello bought 10 but oh sorry forgot
about that bought 10 maybe in the stump
of his neck okay where they connect nope
oh man I don't I don't ever know what
I'm okay I've looked everywhere here
it's gotta be on the second floor do you
guys have you seen it you've probably
seen it some of you've seen it probably
under the plants can I even I can't move
the plants though that doesn't make any
sense
lock the light - the wrong game it's got
to be somewhere maybe
I am us I am I am very stupid and or
whoa okay and lost its gotta be in here
somewhere
if you've seen it if you've seen that
button if you've seen the button tell me
it looks just like a light like button
just if you find it click on it's got to
be it's gotta be on one of the
bookshelves they wouldn't have this many
bookshelves if it wasn't on one of these
goddamn bookshelves and the button
wouldn't be and the button no it's not
the mechanical room button no it's not
the one that plays the music that's not
the one we're talking about it's gotta
be it's gotta be somewhere here can I
just jump no we won't let me the books
mark thank you top books oh if I didn't
know that it was the books Oh in the
books maybe maybe it's there yes of
course it's a book but I just don't know
whoa oh maybe it's yeah maybe you're
right maybe you're right maybe you're
right about that maybe I shouldn't have
mocked you so mercilessly maybe maybe
it's just a pulley book you know oh you
know oh I think you know if you don't
think you know maybe you actually know
maybe it might be one of those those
Yankee books the ones that yank real
hard yeah that might be it yeah this is
a library yeah okay all right yeah all
right okay so I got him mm-hmm
oh yeah I gotta find the book I just
gotta start pulling maybe this is a hint
I think this is a hint wait it's a hint
isn't it
wait this is a hint isn't it
maybe it means two upstairs one
downstairs maybe that's the hint or
maybe I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about but it's a hint ain't it
might be a pulley book everybody bear
with I'm gonna yank that bow I'm gonna
grab that book by its balls I'm really
gonna just no really really Crump that
book I find you it looks if it is a
Yankee book it would look fundamentally
different from the other books that's
just a fact okay I can't I can't I can't
just go but bear with me guys I'll be
right back I have to do this right now
front of you and I have got ya someone
tell me someone tell me someone please
help me I'm so lost sir ma'am lady
someone please
does anybody know nobody cena my god
it's behind the books you were pulling
on who is that mean button this button
right here
she sure is this is a button button
hello this one button man there's got to
be a custom story that hides a button in
the dick of a statue right there's got
to be okay
he's gonna go again go again go from top
to bottom okay
not here not here not here not here I'm
looking at every square inch ooh yeah
every no not there every every square
inch
looking real closer to you oh boy this
world is where I lose it all this is
work oh boy
yeah this is where I started to lose it
it's if it's not here the candle just
one of the candles it's a Yankee candle
you gotta yank the candle it's like a
penis but it's candle that's the answer
that's the secret that's the trick no
tinderbox left but I got one of these
maybe there's it wait a minute why can't
I you said what are you saying this is
but they're not all like that
wait a minute where's that is that the
thing maybe maybe it's uh maybe that's
it maybe I got push the button in there
I got go down I gonna light it maybe
that's it I think that might be it
I think that might be it yeah I think
there's no candles up here that you can
light there's no books to Paul yeah I
think I'm onto something so I got yeah I
got a press that button there's no yank
candles here but wait
Oh what the hell wait am i way what wait
wait
how many of you saw that I believe you
saw then just let me flounder [ __ ]
all right whatever hello hi mine it is
Marga blyer
how are you moving in here do I need to
hide in there I'll keep that open just
in case okay hello this is gonna have
wailing of the Damned nothing okay I'm
looking real close now there's no way
I'm gonna get out of my line inside this
time not this time no no and I know how
he got it
yesterday was the day I finally managed
to enter the prop room not out of
courage but out of desperation the
automaton was not sitting where I left
it
it was sitting by the board with the
pointing stick in hand I took a few
steps back towards the door
then it suddenly started to tap it's
thick at the board of letters to once
again spell out the word hungry a
mysterious substance started to emerge
from the corners of the room the
substance was pitch black and had both
the characteristics of smoke and liquid
it was slithering on the floor towards
me like a bed of serpents when they
reached me it started crawling up my
body until my entire side of you was
engulfed in darkness I wasn't able to
move that's a problem
suddenly the darkness lifted and I found
myself in a dimly lit chamber the size
of which was hard to estimate the
architecture and the overall look of an
old deteriorated dungeon from the void I
could hear the faint sound of dripping
water that's when I saw a shadowy figure
I knew instantly that it was her she was
standing motionless in a basin of water
with large pipes sticking out of the
ceiling above it the only sign at the
time was even Chloe was the dozens of
floating pale corpses the corpses of
children she lifted her arms towards the
ceiling pipes and whispered hissing lee
in a foreign language blood started
streaming out of the pipes and showered
her while she was screaming euphoric Li
AO I could feel the ravenous hunger
practically radiating off her as I
watched the blood flowing down her gray
face the blood of the innocent
blood of the pure the dark substance
emerged again and all faded to black I
woke up on the floor
back at the prot room in the pool of my
own sweat shaking like an orphan in the
cold I now know what she wants me to do
I just don't think I can do it ah
well funny you should mention orphans
cuz I'm pretty sure you murdered some
and I'm gonna I'm gonna crank up the
volume just a bit for you guys so that
you can get the the full full experience
of all this oh yeah just so just just a
little bit just a little bit I think
right there that's gonna be good ye
right there okay okay be a little better
cuz I think now we're gonna start diving
into the spooky part because there's
been a lot of pretence up until this
point there's been a lot of like
build-up and ambience but now we know
there's a ghost lady that really wants
to uh yeah dear mr. Campbell despite our
previous reminders we have still not
received any payment or response from
you therefore we regret to inform you
that if we do not obtain the payment in
full within four months we will have no
other alternatives but to undertake
court actions against you in order to
retrieve the dead amount if you have any
questions regarding current situation
please do not hesitate to contact us
yours truly the Denver Bank okay and
people really write letters weirdly here
hmm can I still not use this lighter
okay can't use it this way so the
lighter is just there for special
reasons so he wasn't making money off of
this seems like he probably should have
been making money off of this
if I just had to guess
okay all right but we got what we needed
so I'm assuming we can get out of here
right with no problems all right so far
so good what did I get to keep you
anyway
the second floor okay good that's great
that's real good baby okay didn't think
that I was gonna be able to go it was an
open casket funeral he had never seen a
dead body before the sight was a bleak
imitation of the horrors he could paint
on the canvas of darkness while lying
awake at night okay all right so
straight up to the second floor then I
guess
nothing weird about that time does pass
here so that's that's good good to know
all right okay nothing nothing weird
mother fell to the floor
tears were beginning to well in her eyes
as she begged him to look at her he
would not grant her wish she packed her
bags and left okay good I mean not good
oh this uh this don't look is nice
everything else all nice maintain this
one yeah this one not so nice okay some
kind of it's like an Aztec pyramid or
something oh nope okay not go no I know
I know a trap when I see one I'm gonna
save that one for way later everyone
just put that out of your minds everyone
just put that out of your minds don't
even know all right not that one either
are we we've been picking some bad doors
Sunday we're gonna get a good door here
okay this it's okay so either I could
try to brute-force it or I could try to
go find a coat I'm pretty sure that
journal entries it's gonna be there are
some weird numbers okay see it with the
mechanical locking device I need to
figure out the combination okay you got
it buddy you got it buddy boo all right
so we got door number one which is
horrible and then we got door number two
which is even worse so I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna go down door number
one boy I'm closing myself I'm not gonna
give you the chance to close it and lock
it on me
it's it's like stupidly dark see I
wasn't too far off please do not
hesitate to contact us see I wasn't too
far off okay I turned that off to save
oil while we were listening to that but
that was the same as the letter upstairs
I wonder why they did a duplicate oh
okay it's locked in will not open with a
key I didn't want to go with the
archives anyway yeah I barely even
finished being in here okay a little
more light here which is kind of nice
hippo hello oh boy alright this is the
sitting room really thunk about some
stuff I haven't eaten for days Oh too
bad
every time I try to swallow I feel a
clutching force around my throat Darth
Vader she wants to star me like I'm
starving her
she's everywhere that she is relentless
Wow even now as I'm typing this I can
feel her cold hands upon my shoulders I
don't even bother turning around anymore
would it bullet through my temple who
really end this
I wonder or would she be on the other
side waiting for me in either case I'm
too much of a coward to pull the trigger
oh yeah yeah but it's perfectly clear to
me that there are only two possible
outcomes to this new reality I find
myself in if the lamp tries to fight off
the lion one may admire his courage but
not his judgment sometimes I guess it's
not bad with these attempts to justify
myself if I were to choose to do her
bidding
other times much better option to just
go ahead and try to kidnap and murder
some children
oh okay great okay all right anyway
Thank You Gavin Huckabee for the super
chat Thank You dilly-dally daily soldier
Jesus okay it's lock-in o'clock does
that mean that there's like uh some kind
of mechanical device in here so
something here was there like a oh maybe
the paintings no okay well that's that's
lovely
okay it's a lovely room of death but why
am i okay I guess there's no reason to
be here so maybe move on to the time
being okay that's an option thank you
that valuable input really appreciate it
okay Lockton will not open well the key
there's a lot of locked doors in this
area I don't much appreciate it it's not
really my favorite thing but you know
I'll deal with it I guess
oh all right weird just a strange room
of darkness back here I thought the rest
of the place had electricity this this
entire wing seems to be run exclusively
off of candles
I'm gonna bed some snacks Locker loyal
thank you for that
some nights are made for reflection and
the savoring of loneliness last night
was one of those nights the lampposts
cast an entourage of lights dancing
across the puddles on the street the
dense fog made me feel very anonymous
which in turn reminded me that these
shadowy events are invisible to the
world no yes you're okay I had never
felt more alone yogya in the poorly lit
street corner i saw an orphan girl
begging for change she had red wavy hair
and slanted green eyes her face was
dirty and held the look of defeat with a
simple sleight of hand
I managed to make her giggle
pure of heart she followed me home wait
a haired child through your sacrifice my
name last eternal I knew that was coming
a long way away but even so it's just
like oh god what a douche what an
unbelievable douche
what an incredible unimaginably
unbelievable douche okay but there's got
to be something here there's a reason
this reason I'm going through this place
there's so many keys that I need to
unlock the other doors okay oh hi oh no
that's not good
[Music]
okay all right we're gonna we're gonna
ignore that we're gonna ignore that one
whoa whoa
what you want to do with me why don't
you want anything to do with me
what do I have to do with this I'm just
trying to rescue my brother apparently I
just want to go home I don't even want
to be here
okay so there's some kind of a lock but
I'm not even sure the device is here let
alone something that I could access
right now so for the time being I'm just
gonna assume I didn't get anything new
so I'm just gonna assume that maybe it's
a different area of this place yeah
whatever
I can go upstairs let me go upstairs to
the other area see what was going on
there this place is not fun
maybe upstairs will be better I've art
I've always heard that uh laboratories
are a fun place for the whole family to
be hello Oh Pleasant okay here Boyle or
such the like ass oh it's not oil and
this please don't be creepy sounds a
whole lot of nothing
great good no I'm glad I'm very happy
was it laboratory oh it's a laboratory
within the laboratory okay
oh thank you
well this place looks fun can't wait to
see what's waiting for me up here okay
all right what do we got here what did
it say please don't be just there's a oh
there is a sophisticated laboratory on
the second floor
well good what is that do me though oh
yes
keep the key to bit somewhere in this
area so that's got to be one of the
downstairs keys right probably should
come up here first we've got a box got
some boxes
some kind of mysterious white dews I
don't really want to know what that's
all about but guess gets lonely up in
little bored is more no all right plenty
of opium but that seems about it so what
I'm probably gonna have to do is I'm
probably gonna have to go get
ingredients and come back here and then
try to make something that's usually how
this works here oh this looks nice
oh that's not so nice oh that's even
less nice okay great nothing this a
whole lot of nothing there's so many
things to explore that I'm just I'm just
meticulously going through everything
just in case I miss something and when
you know if there's Oh what is this not
I don't like that that doesn't open okay
all right I guess there's uh nothing in
there
nothing it's locked for no reason maybe
okay all right okay leaving drying the
key downstairs great great good good in
fact great okay okay
chair abuse I'm not cherub look behind
me oh well you look behind you
whatever lurking this game might have
decided to jump ship and go over to your
house maybe here no okay there was
another door over here somewhere
probably could be unlocked now that was
a mechanical device that unlocks that
one so it's got to be was this door here
locked I believe yes please yes okay ooh
this looks like a storeroom maybe I can
get something greedy what am I said
about creepy laughing I said nothing
about that
no don't write a note about that oh
you're stupid observation there's a
hatch leading into the Attic on the
second floor I need to find a ladder to
reach it okay I've got a lot of
requirements right now not a lot of
answers okay well I got the oil you
couldn't get me kind of snap my fingers
okay wooden bucket I could probably get
some water out of the leak in the main
area if that's really what I need but I
don't know I would be just water
whatever seems like it's the only thing
in here all right eventually I'll get
that I don't want to get that but
eventual get that okay so we got that
get some water maybe if that's what I
gotta do
okay all right that's fine that's
definitely okay let's try to get some
water see if that's the way to do it uh
it is okay got a bucket of water okay
great
goody goody gumdrops what do I do with
it
there might be some like maybe I gotta
extinguish a some kind of fire somewhere
has got to be like either either it's
even the bulk of the water is used in
this experimentation up here or it's
used in some capacity to unlock the
quote-unquote mechanical switch someone
somewhere else no not that it's probably
definitely almost definitely not here
it's got to be down below so let's go
down below I don't like the random
noises let's go say it right now I don't
like no random enough there was nothing
over there else I think there was that
the weird locked like closet which I
don't trust in any capacity I've also
got I've got a lighter that goes to some
mystery whatever have you I also may
need this bucket in some other location
but all I know is that there's a
mechanical switch that needs to be done
here maybe it's to extinguish this it is
I don't like that but uh that that
really did it that really did it dammit
well did something so glad I put out
that fire whoa there it is okay uh-huh
[Music]
I feel good about myself I feel like I'm
a big smarty oh this is the Sears room
okay exchange was made and she held her
end of the bargain tonight's performance
was met with standing ovations later in
the lounge
Mr Cameron popped open a bottle of the
finest champagne and we drank straight
out of the bottle but I couldn't
suppress last night's events well enough
to celebrate convincingly I told Cameron
I wasn't feeling too well and was going
to take a carriage home he looked very
surprised and somewhat disappointed he
told me that he was looking forward to
tomorrow night's performance
I waved frantically to the first carrier
I spotted and told the driver to take me
to the slums in order not to suffer
another longmont Fiasco I needed to see
to her needs
I needed to supply her with yet another
child a child a day a child every day
that's I mean one is too many child okay
alright
sorry in his act he had broken free from
shackles a thousand times and more these
shackles however he was unable to escape
so much for the amazing I'll do and he
thought all right well good great ok
we're all what has happened I can't move
oh oh no I got a bad feeling about the
darkness lifted
not eval myself in a dimly lit chamber
size which was hard to estimate oh okay
from the void and I could hear the faint
sounds of dripping water okay that's
when I saw shadow you feel ravenous
hunger raiding offer they hit him like
an array of pulsating waves of feverish
heat sounds oddly sexual but somehow I
don't think that this is supposed to be
that okay all right that all I needed to
see that's all the okay that was fun
that was fun that was fun I ten out of
ten on Yelp okay archive key okay so we
got the archives key that's good that
means we'll probably have to come back
to the to the laboratory at some point
later okay but at least we know that
we're totally utterly and completely
boned in every possible way
let's get EOD where was the wait the
archives no that was right here that was
right here why do I need to go down to
the archives the archives sound old
dusty and probably full of horrible
things you'd rather read somewhere about
a culture in which water was a symbol
for obsession for a while now he'd
thought that maybe his father drowned in
both what water or obsession hello hello
oh I thought that was kinda boxed in for
a while okay there's a weird buzzing in
my ears that's nice that's real nice
okay hello
don't see anything of importance right
away that doesn't mean there couldn't be
something later okay nope whole lot of
nothing I just got a bad feeling about
this area something tells me it's not
gonna be fun for me all right
nothing so far okay thank you okay thank
you
ah good another note tell me more about
your horrible horrible horrible deeds
every soul I bring her image grows ever
more defined
she uses the lifeless souls of children
to gradually make her way back into the
world of the living once she reaches her
magnum opus I will be of no importance
to her a few days ago I sent a letter to
James Warren a paranormal researcher
that specifies inspector ology despite
being extensively ridiculed by the
scientific community his controversial
research goes back decades in his reply
he told me about the silver cord which
is the tether that binds our astral
spirits to our physical bodies
if severed the physical body perishes
this cord can only be interacted with a
few like the court itself are in a state
between life and death
okay silver cord is the bridge through
which she accesses this world severing
the cord would banish her to where she
came
although admittingly a complicated task
I have to find a way okay you have to
find a way now not not before you
sacrifice numerous children to it and
you know generally made yourself out to
be a horrible murderous son of a [ __ ]
but yeah okay now now's good I guess now
is better than never
all right whoa hello weird roofie slin
hello anybody in there hello hello okay
I can't go there what is that buzz
oh wait did I just make a loop oh I did
make a loop de loop okay never mind did
I get everything in here I couldn't
there's no way there has to be something
else no I did wait what
wait no oh sorry my brain just got mess
with that's not a loop that's it's just
looked like it was a loop I why didn't I
realize it cuz I couldn't go in that way
I'm sorry my brain just completely
farted out my ass there I had no idea
what was happening
okay alright
I still got these flies in my ear which
is real cool okay what's this oh the
book is displayed symbols oh boy oh boy
I love magic symbols oh boy I love
unknown magic symbols that I can put
into things and stuff
I can't open these all right let's go
back I guess hopefully those wrote down
did those write down properly girls I'm
gonna be very upset there's a dead body
okay it's does this dead there's a dead
body that's all that's right I have no
other journals dead that's all I wrote
unless there was like two pages to the
journal no pitched oh there are okay
plant it tree mood got it all right
plant tree mood got it okay plant it
tree moon planted tree moon got it got
it got it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
hey Waldo um I have nowhere to hide oh
no bomba ha ha ha
[Music]
um oh hi oh no
well
Oh
that can stop anytime that dot that can
go away literally now okay she I don't
know if she's gone oh whoa whoa whoa
Bank Bank why what are you cheating are
you we're I'd uh [ __ ] it's fine
literally not horrible hi okay hello hi
how are you my name is markiplier what
are you what are you doing oh okay
here's my chance it's my chance if you
make a loop-de-loop we're gonna make a
loop-d-loop that's good okay now are you
making a loop-de-loop or are you am I
fooling myself you went down the door oh
no
no no no no how about no how about a
whole lot of no I'm just gonna go it and
I should be fine Pramod off the scream
from the hallway grip the tear in the
fabric that was his sanity
his mind was swirling in a whirlpool of
Atlas a whirlpool in a vast ocean of
darkness spinning about a hole in the
void
okay all right totally fine nothing to
worry about
not a problem no problemo totally on a
person cool planet tree moon we know
plan to tree moon that's what we got and
that's where we're going I almost had it
oh there's only three symbols I could
have guessed this I probably could have
there we go whoa
there is no you read some about a
culture in which water was assumed oh I
already knew about that one I already
knew about that one that's fine
Oh peaceful I'm sure it'll be totally
fine so uh
Sully ultimate custom night is nearing
release the king of five nights at
Freddy's needs to return yeah I'm gonna
be doing that it's gonna take forever
but I'm gonna be doing it what I'm
probably gonna do with ultimate custom
night is I'm going to be probably just
live-streaming it because it's not
really a game where there's a story it's
just like custom night mode so I'll
probably just livestream me doing
multiple multiple attempts for a few
hours a day to see if I can work myself
up because it's just gonna be like skill
base with that many custom characters
it's just gonna need repetition and
understanding like that's all it is it's
just gonna be practice as far as the eye
can see so that's gonna take hours and
hours and hours so might as well
document the whole thing yeah okay why
am I looking at this oh I'm in it it's
the Big Dipper or is it the Little
Dipper it's a dipper of some kind all
right I saw a dippy dip
I saw dippin dots they're the future of
ice cream what the hell am I even
looking at light bulbs why that's weird
okay they've got some amnesia for
amnesia a machine for pigs stuff here
I'm an amnesia for pigs they got that
didn't you know
what was that like some clicking was
that did I just make that am I crazy did
I hear did you guys hear that No
I swear I'm not I'm not crazy right I
heard some kind of like weird clicking
in that's probably nothing probably just
part of the ambiance it was being crazy
oh now is probably good yes I don't know
if these need to be down there but I'm
gonna put him down there except for that
one over in the window there we go
there's nothing on the banisters okay oh
my ankle all right what was the point of
that what was the point of turning off
the light unless there was only so much
power to use and now I've rerouted it in
a way is that a possibility I don't see
any kind of mechanisms turn on power
down here so like yes that's that can't
be it that that can wait wait a minute
wait a minute it's a constellation Oh
Oh look at me I didn't even notice the
scrapes on the floor but oh look at me
look at me look at me yeah it's another
spoken chair so someone can sit around
and just go oh as soon as you walk down
surprised they didn't do that
nothing great good good to know what is
that what is this stuff the technology
seems to be a little inconsistent around
here cultures all over the world have
found ways to disembody their
consciousness to get closer to the
regards okay sure I found a rare book
about an occult Guild of Greek or Roman
alchemists their experiments resulted in
a neurotoxic brew they called Portus
mortis which roughly translates to
death's gate the brewing involves the
combination of a very rare strain of
mushroom as well as ectoplasm and a
human heart of course the heart the
mushroom contains a powerful neurotoxin
that slows the heart rate and breathing
to virtually nothing the heart and the
ectoplasm contains the essence of the
living and the dead respectively
ectoplasm is a white gelatinous
substance which could potentially remain
where a spirit has manifested itself to
complete the crossover however one must
be deprived of their sense of weight
this is most effectively achieved by
being underwater conveniently enough my
father's Chinese water tank still stands
in the prot room the very same tank
which I watched my father drown in 20
years ago it's rather poetic in a way no
it's not necessary ingredients will
definitely take some time I fear that I
need to commit one last night of
harvesting to avoid her suspicions
starving orphan might be easier to
seduce but a child of privilege full of
life should keep her satisfied
don't use the word seduced in that
context I don't care I don't care what
you're saying don't do that look nothing
about this entire operation is pleasant
and if you can just hand me over Sammy
so that you know can get this over with
it's gonna come down to a choice of
being like but this will banish your
forever if you sacrifice your brother
and I could be like or you could die
that's also an option if you just like
you know do that did I get it oh I got a
wax cylinder wait wait wait wait there
was a wait there was a it was a cranky
tank there was a cranky wanky there was
something over here I could probably put
it in over here I don't need to run all
the way back to that one that I have no
idea where it is but I got one here okay
yeah oh I do got a run all the way back
to the other one god damn it why even
had that there if you're just gonna
tempt me with it maybe it's just to like
remind me that oh I ran into one of
those before I remember that very
greatly good thing I'm putting all these
notes in my book all right so we got to
run back to wherever the hell that was
we'll make progress he woke up as the
Sun was reddening and for a second
everything felt normal but it wasn't oh
yeah cranky Alexes Smith said please
consider revisiting stranded deep it has
really come a long way I've been playing
it like crazy and updates are consistent
so there's uh is more to do oh that's
good I haven't even thought about
stranded deep in forever yeah is there a
main-floor peculiar model of phonograph
okay I think I know where that is which
is always weird cuz stranded deep is a
game where you're stranded on an island
not underwater which is a different game
that I've actually never blues that game
that where you get stranded underwater I
can't even remember what that was I
never actually played it I know I never
made any videos of it either
I guess that falls into the same
category but you know what I mean yeah
it's
remember oh yeah there's a lot of like
space program simulator games that I
haven't had a chance to visit either
someday someday I shall ok so somewhere
down here somewhere down here is this
where the body is yeah that's where the
body is okay is that always there didn't
notice that before okay but maybe over
here I can't quite recall it's been so
long no not there but this leads through
hello uh hello okay oh oh wait no I've
opened all these before oh I didn't even
try that door before did I maybe I did I
can't remember photograph where the hell
are you photograph photograph wasn't it
here
what hell was that it sounded like
something whispered in my ear oh god I'm
losing it
Bob lose oh I'm losing it I'm losing it
right in here I'm gonna lose it
okay nothing is it alone nothing you're
still nothing all right cool good great
glad that happened
okay all right let's plop her in that
snot out piano works
[Music]
wait okay
what's it
[Music]
well like the same thing I did I do
whoa
Oh
who built this what contractors are they
hired to build the giant moving wall who
built that that's what I always wonder
whenever you have a house with like
moving parts it who built it
why does it always work 100% of the time
properly
oh yeah okay all right
all right cool you built it you I don't
I don't believe you Bob the Builder I
don't think builder oh the black
[Music]
what's over there something's on the
ground over there I don't know what that
is man there's a ton of like it areas in
this game where I haven't visited yet or
I've seen but I haven't been able to get
through it's really nice to be good
Sammy Sammy
[Music]
so happy
that's not good why my why my Ling okay
swearing don't worry Sammy I'm coming
for you I don't think that's Oh chapter
chapter two that was all this chapter
oneness whoa looks like we may be in for
a long night cuz that was just chapter
one then maybe there's like it maybe
it's like a three chapter thing though I
liked it I was just about to say that I
really liked it because the first
chapter I didn't even know it was a
chapter when I was gonna say but the
first arc of this story took you through
the entirety of the house and like
showed you pretty much everything and
it's like there's uh there's parts of it
that are gonna be useful later useful
sooner did I get everything down there
I'm gonna just double check because I
don't wanna have to come back down here
but like it took you through the
entirety of the house and then there's
just like there's other things to see
like as you go through it again but it's
not like it's not like a lot of running
back it's like showing you sorry sorry I
didn't mean to step on you like that
okay I got everything I needed but it's
not like running back and forth it's
it's procedure really going forward
through it and then going back and like
unlocking things I forget like what
other games like have that mechanic it's
it's like maybe I can hammer it oh there
we go yeah it's like many games do that
where you're in one hub location but you
go around walkable Wade
[Music]
okay before entering the tank it needs
to be filled with water and the Porta
smartest potion needs to be brewed Oh ah
that's what I meant by I'm so what who's
doing that don't it's all it it only
sounds like it's buying me house I don't
like that I hate that I hate that I hate
that oh it's just tickling the back of
my brain oh god that's awful
yes sorry I just had a visceral reaction
to that oh there we go I got a ladder
wait I can get up to the attic now I
know what I'm gonna do with this ladder
it's a bomb I don't think bombs it's not
really a ticking it sounds like
someone's winding something up I don't
know why something here behind the
curtain of course of course of course
oh god damn it I just filled a car let
me explore the rest of this area first
and then I'll go fill my tank darn it
whoa what's this area
I saw I'll come back and get that oil
later
[Music]
well this is a rather grim and dark
looking basement oh it's lovely this is
Oh perfect place for a monster to hide
[Music]
your deck Franken I don't like it none
at all is there something behind there
no okay really weird Oh what's this
thermite cranking stop no it's still
there okay good the old comfortable
cranking but why do I need to throw
though why do I need thermite
oh hey I hate this whole place I hate it
all of it
I hate it I hate that that was awful
okay well laughs thermite now there I
can fill that up there's a cranky again
all right you know what I'm just gonna
go up here see what's up here and then
I'm out of here
[Music]
which way am I going gone there's no
running water through the pipe okay so I
got it like what turn on the turn on the
paper if everything I've read is true
Sammy's in the astral plane and I might
be able to bring him back I need to
gather the following ingredients to brew
the porters more this potion a human
heart ectoplasm neurotoxic mushrooms so
I there's a human heart right there on
the floor like that dead guy in order to
fill up the water tank I need to
redirect the water flow to the proper
room okay so I got to do that somehow I
don't know what that flash was all right
so I need some sort of a knife to cut
the heart out of this dude but I don't
need it right now
let me not hammer it out of them but
some tells me that's not gonna work
properly so I got a ladder and a key to
the conservatory which I know where that
is
so let me hit let me get out of here hit
the conservatory first don't like that
room the facial features of the
automaton was carefully detailed Van
Doren must have really missed his son
yeah yes um about that oh geez
yeah thank you - Kyle murrow's for the
super chat oh man how it all started I
love this game yeah this amnesia this is
where it all started
super weird to think about but it's
really is it okay
nothing all right okay all right that's
the best you can do huh Danny nothing
ain't nothing a whole lot of nothing
old ah dick diddly over there being the
son of a famous magician odds are it
made a very skeptical mind his worldview
has was very bleak compared to the
colorful beliefs of the other children
oh okay I get it I thought I'd read that
one before but it didn't seem so what do
we got here let's do this there's shadow
over there
what kind of conservatory is this what
is a conservatory anyway was a
conservatory for is that for music
don't like it Oh Oh it's a garden okay
why is there okay why is there uh why
are there metal grates underneath it why
is that there okay I mean it's nice I
guess when you really look at it oh uh
violin sorry
um yes I don't have to try to hunt down
Sammy anymore can I do it stuck
I don't have enough muscle I didn't eat
my Wheaties all right that's gonna be
okay all right let's go downstairs I'm
starting to realize that I don't need to
look everywhere if there's not like
directly a puzzle in relation to what
I'm doing Oh No
[Music]
okay all right well Wow weird place to
put book we're weird weird place to put
books you'd think that they wouldn't
need to be in a musty damp cellar Oh
like this every uh-oh yeah okay all
right is this where you grow your weed
why do you why is this so secluded why
is there an oven what are you growing
mushroom got it one of four great great
oh that's the knife I'm gonna cut the
heart out with they said no one I'm
doing a vow on this legend traces back
to a Lakhia during the reign of the
Ottoman Empire it tells the story of
Victoria grigoris the head nurse at the
mental institution of Bucharest at the
time boki a large portion of the
patients suffered from psychosocial
incapacities associated with old age but
this being her everyday surrounding she
gradually became more and more obsessed
with the concept of aging and death
complaints from the patient's about
occult activities and imagery around the
institution was not uncommon
unfortunately the complaints were simply
disregarded as mass hysteria young women
began to disappear from villages near
and far desperate girls were lured by
offers of well-paid work as nurses and
were never seen again as tears past her
victims grew younger in age and gender
stopped being a criteria the legend
states that she bathed in the blood of
hundreds of children with the belief
that she could absorb their life force
and subsequently prolong her life her
gruesome activities earned her a
plethora of names but the red nurse
became the most prevalent there are as
many twists to this tale as there are
people telling it but there are some
motifs that keep reappearing there is no
doubt in my mind that this is the woman
that haunts me
okay all right sounds bad sounds bad all
around yeah I don't know what to say
about that uh
can you just point me towards where the
other mushrooms are I just need to go on
a trip to forget how you killed my
brother all right whatever
yeah I just don't like this long hallway
why would they build a long hallway
there if it didn't didn't he build
behave okay just look over a chance he's
like destroy all anime I'm like what
kind of what kind of what kind of
campaign are you trying to run over
there and chat well I'm not looking
around okay well I got one mushroom does
that mean there's four other mushrooms
somewhere in this garden or is this like
or they're just like four mushroom
strewn about willy-nilly all over the
place and I need to smash it up to find
everything yeah happy bday it's not my
birthday is it someone's birthday and
chat happy birthday everybody sing happy
birthday all at the same time I'll give
you five bucks if you manage to do it
maybe I have some kind of like lubricant
maybe I could blow it up with thermite
maybe that's what I could do nope okay
all right none of that so I don't see
any other mushrooms here at whoa oh oh
don't worry I'm gonna eat the shrooms oh
the shrooms are gonna be consumed Hey
Baby I've ever showed you my my chair
skills and didn't quite see you sneaking
up in the in the brush like that they
definitely they definitely put their
first specific reason so you just see
angel blood on the way out
all right that's gotta be like uh that's
gotta be like some kind of a homage to
the red nurse that he was talking about
over there yeah yeah whoever's birthday
my birthday is this month but it is not
today lamb okay I don't see any more
marshes it sounds like a thin mountain
air as realest aveer lis dulled your
senses my friend I'm deeply worried
about you Cornelius we all do things we
desperately wish we could undo sometimes
they double pull some strings that make
us dance we fight to lighten the most
loathsome of the things that later fills
us with regret those regrets just become
part of who we are
along with everything else honestly
Cornelius what could you possibly have
done to make yourself so irredeemable
your concern ed friend Alfred Cameron
also your manager but that's beside okay
all right put that fire known over there
okay we've got one mush great I'm
guessing the other mushers are screwed
about everywhere
maybe there's a mush in the toilet I
didn't even think about that
hello no emotion toilet Cory my birthday
is Monday I'll be 28 I'm donating to a
suicide prevention charity on Facebook
if you do that - that'd be awesome yeah
I actually did earlier today I made a
contribution because there was like
Anthony Bourdain and Kate Spade just
like recently sorry to bring this up out
of the blue but it was just like in the
news everywhere they recently committed
suicide and it's just like it's such a
tragedy to see and like it's just
something that's always like always in
my mind and I wasn't want to make sure
that everybody knows that if you're
going through depression and you have
any thoughts of self-harm or suicide
like reach out to someone there they're
like the the overall understanding of
depression and suicide is like it's
bringing more attention to everybody
because there's still people that don't
take it as a serious thing especially
when it comes to depression there's a
lot of people that don't take depression
like seriously they they think it's just
an attitude adjustment they don't
realize that it's it's just this
crippling pain that some people try to
go through life with and bare but
sometimes it's just absolutely
unbearable so if you're having any
thoughts about this please reach out to
someone the national suicide hotline a
friend and if you're going if you're
just fine like reach out to a friend if
you're even remotely concerned that they
may be having a rough time
just send them a like a text that just
says you're thinking about them that's
that's really all it is and open up the
door that they can talk to you at any
time I think that's what's important
okay anyway uh second floor attic hatch
upstairs got it that's where I'm headed
now all right let's go let's go my
birthday's on the 28th
of June this month if you were curious
about that yeah today you turn 16 well
happy birthday to you Logan
I've been watching you and your channel
since the slender haunt days you ever
think about doing haunt again in the
future
slender haunt I don't even remember that
game there's so many slender games it
how can I like I don't even remember
specifically one slender game out of the
plethora that I saw but slender horn oh
special about that one I'm trying to
remember I can't I can't actually
remember anything about it yeah you're
turning 20 oh man so many birthdays this
month well happy birthday happy happy a
happy birthday
oh yeah oh I don't like the way that
side when I open
hello okay it's fine oh it's not fine
he opened his bedroom door and waited
for his eyes to adjust to the darkness
but no shape or contour appeared okay
all right that's good
are you gonna play west of loathing
again not unless there's like extra
content I you know when I played it I
reached the end I was like well I didn't
reach all the end but then it just gets
to like 100% agam and completionist at
that point and that was like I didn't
really want to do that I grinded quite a
bit to get to where I was in the game so
I figured that'd be enough oh this is
sad oh this is already sad I don't like
it okay all right Oh squeak hello who's
there
Oh mousie mousie all right well you
better run things are probably gonna get
bad up here
[Music]
okay things are probably fine where the
hell are you even going I don't even
understand where I'm supposed to go oh
hi
okay yeah that's yeah that's uh yeah oh
oh did I did I make a big circle or did
I go the right way I think I went the
right way something here anyway hello
hello nothing just goes on forever okay
who lives up here this is where grandma
was this is where you put grandma on you
couldn't hear her cries cuz she's in the
very back of a giant attic who who
sleeps here in the punishment corner who
does it why do you have so many bedrooms
you're you're single oh good it's that
band that we all love I love the way
they sample real life sounds great okay
good glad excuse me we needed that there
mushroom up here whoa ectoplasmic goo i
find a jar filled with mysterious white
fluid and i pick it up I'm like Oh a
Plaza
I know ectoplasm I definitely can tell
ectoplasm from a charge is I do I know
straight up in my head I know
oh yeah that's ectoplasm alright let me
put that in my pocket you know I don't
even need a jar for it I was just I was
wearing on my skin I'll get it later I
need to go into the tub anyway probably
that's right that's probably good enough
for me excuse me can I borrow this thank
you alright anything else over here
other than the ectoplasm that I very
clean oh no
[Music]
Oh mom enough
how patiently sheltered what but not a
key I flip it down how do i up pipe
behind here this will hurt hurt
that is real good hidey-hole boo boy
limited stack a box in front of my face
[Music]
oh boy well there she is okay all right
there there she is there all this [ __ ]
she's there okay okay there she is
dude I don't know how I'm still alive I
don't know you think I know I'm still
alive I have no idea no I haven't got a
goddamn clue I'm good goddamn clue but I
think I'm well I showed her
it was my jar of ectoplasm that really
scared her off there she didn't want to
go anywhere near me I don't know why
wonderful okay
why does that go up I'm already in the
Attic why would I need to go up why do I
buy a why up this questionnaire why oh I
mean they do say when people talk about
me that I got mad UPS they often do I
recall hearing people say that why can't
I go Kay but uh
Bulgaria's oh boy there we go okay where
what why what
oh is this just like a way to bypass her
ow I see this was just a way to get away
from her
oh never mind no I was at owing for the
wrong reasons okay alright we're good I
guess
it's getting out of here wherever we can
get IATI hmm okay all right we're good
okay we're good yeah the rumor is that
the ultimate custom night will be
released sometime in around the
anniversary date of the original five
nights at freddys which I believe was in
August but there's also rumors that it
could be June July it's not rumors
because this guy or Ascot this guy Scott
has said that he wants to try to get it
out on that day
so hopefully hopefully we'll know before
him because he's been very opening up up
front about like what he wants to do and
how he wants to do it so that's good ok
so I got the ectoplasm I got a one
mushroom not four so I just got a uh
what's my next it's my next thing I've
got I've got thermite I don't know where
that would be maybe there's like a
padlock that I need to wait seller on
the main floor is locked by a metal
padlock I could use the thermite on that
use the lighter to light it on fire
on the main floor okay so yeah let's do
that
let's do that let's do that let's try
that that's probably what I need to go
oh it says June 29th my birthday oh
that's that's nice that's real nice
there yeah that'd be real cool that'd be
real cool and then I can fail over and
over and over again and I can die and
die over and over and over again I can
get to meet all these cool people that
I'm gonna hate that'd be nice ok it said
cellar door on the main floor area so I
call there being another one over here
but this is the main floor area over
here is the bathroom that's not where I
need to go what's at the end of all the
way over there I can't recall ah this
was it this was it's this was definitely
eat let's try this yeah scoop it on
there that's definitely how thermite
behaves light it that's all so ya did it
I'm so smart with my big brain into the
cellar we're all good things must go
hell yeah
let's do this I'm so ready I am trash
number one mark I can't believe you're
still playing amnesia it's been so long
I still remember some of those episodes
coming out from baby marking me with the
shark
hell yeah my faux hawk I was rocking
that look so long Santa Fe's audio
whines oh good I remember the wine
cellar from the original amnesia that
sure was a fun time
come on this guy's oh you wouldn't put
all this back here and not put some
there I can't believe you I can't
believe you that's a lot of wine what
are they how do they even get a barrel
that big down here they have regular
shipments of giant barrels of wine
coming down here okay waterworks oh I
can get the water diverted down here
that's something good okay all right
there we go I doubt they're gonna bring
the water monster
they're definitely not gonna just
definitely not they wouldn't do that and
wouldn't do that man the water monster
is something that like in all of like
horror games that I played
nothing has been able to replicate the
moments with the water monster then like
then since the original amnesia oh no oh
no I saw those peepers looking at me for
my own no teddy sprinkles
oh boy okay I don't know where
last night
I do not oh boy
but I didn't expire I didn't expect that
sure is a lot of moaning happening down
here yeah a little bit
okay all right back into it okay well I
really royally pooped that up pretty
strongly let's see if I can unpin a tit
it okay so if the noises get louder
I mean she's nearby oh she's nearby
Wow okay all right drama queen much
thanks Miss moose woman
or dare she go not look behind me
she just turned around okay she oh
that's the fire okay she just turned
around so there's gotta be up here maybe
yeah there's got to be like some way to
turn off the fire get away from her okay
what am I looking at what am I looking
at what am I looking at come on come on
come on aha how's there no valve huh
how's that house there no valve how can
there be no valve can make it down here
no I'm gonna get oh the grating is very
loose ball pried open with a knife how
about I just smash it with a box okay
all right then well I need a crowbar
apparently okay
there's no cool bar in here right okay
all right gotta go
all right we gotta go somewhere else and
I guess that's fine
it's definitely fun his death
what's their machine carts yes give me a
Kroeber give me AK rubber rubber cover
screwdriver I'll take a screwdriver
anything else ok nothing let's just go
for it
hmm
screwdriver please work please work yes
okay got it oh I don't think she can get
me down here probably probably not okay
there's no way that she'd be able to get
me down here
oh where am I
hmm okay where is this there's some up
valve yes
divert cover covered the water yes yes
yes okay that's good I guess I would
thought there would have been a more
confirmatory thing that that actually oh
that just turned off the fire oh okay
well that's not as exciting
oh I guess you're done
all right totally fine totally fine
everything's fine everything's hunky
doopy all right well let's go wherever
this leading me down and try to divert
that water so we can fill up a tank and
then promptly die which is exactly what
I was hoping for okay one two three four
I know what this adds up to 500 now it's
out of my realm of possibility I have no
idea where its leading me okay there's a
piece of pipe there but that's not what
I need some kind of something here this
good lock the can open it okay so if
there's got to be there's no
instructions I don't just want to start
spinning valves willy-nilly on me that
sounded good good
I'm sure this isn't gonna catastrophic
Li burst all the pipes in this entire
place also what happens if to someone
first a pipe in this hellhole what would
that actually do what I do that sounds
awfully impressive but you're not gonna
you seriously not gonna give me any like
instructions or anything like that no
clue is this a clue three one two - no
I'm not I'm not gonna assume that I did
it because there was no like there was
no like there was no schwa so if there's
no schwa I'm gonna assume
there's got to be like instructions
somewhere else maybe she's not
patrolling around anymore and I can look
around here for instructions because I
don't think I'm doing something right in
fact I'm willing to bet money that I'm
not doing something right so there's got
to be something else here that can tell
me if I'm doing something right there's
instructions here look or note some
yummy tummy right she better not still
be done
I'm going down here too recklessly for
her to still be wandering around
no it's nothing this is the this is a
loop again
do you guys know you guys know you guys
know what it is have you have you had a
some kind of clue or something some idea
might give it away there was nothing in
that room right there was nothing in the
room the only other thing that I could
guess is like just to leave them all
open but I would assume we were did it
yeah I would assume that the ladder or
the the little thing the little doodad
er the little doodad er would have would
have liked it would have opened because
that seems like it's an open Amol thing
maybe there's a clue up here in the
other room maybe I have no idea I mean
these are all a series of tubes so
that's probably the early internet but
uh I have no idea no book no nothing no
diagram no nothing let me let me just
real quickly let me go back here just in
case I don't want to miss nothing I feel
like maybe there was a note or something
like that now is it too much of a hurry
because I'm just a giant [ __ ] baby oh
they're still whisper
nah nah dude nah dude nah dude nah nah
dude nah dude they're nothing there's
nothing a whole lot of nothing did Sammy
boy is dead
Sammy's dad died
[Applause]
thank you it's me Louie MSP I love you
too
oh also yeah thank you for everyone
that's become a sponsor that's
apparently a new thing that appeared on
my channel so that is a thing I don't
know what to do with it yet I I like did
preliminary just like basic emojis and
stuff but uh I don't know what to do
with it fully yet so I'm gonna
experiment and get back to you at some
point in the future I feel like I'd have
to do more regular live streams to
really have something for that but I'd
like to do something I think it'd be fun
nothing all right so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna spin them all open and I'm
assumed that's what it's supposed to do
if this even is open actually what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna close them all
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna open them 1
2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 just in case that's
what it wants me to do I don't know
whether they're 2 4 1 5 3 I think you
guys are just saying random numbers
that doesn't I don't I don't know who to
trust and I'm gonna try one two three
four where's the money Lebowski but
where's my money
sorry sis you good for it where's the
[ __ ] money man
well one two three four five definitely
wasn't it let me check my journal just
in case there's not like a note or
something I have no idea
no no no anyway whatever I'll just try
that
there's no six and there's no nine I
can't try 69 it's impossible
I'm gonna go back because they're all
technically in the open position I
probably didn't do it in the right order
but there's no way that I'm gonna be
able to guess that so I just got to go
back and look for something else there's
another thing that I can do I'm in this
cellar right now but I can go cut the
heart out of the dead body I just saw my
notes they said there was a dead body in
the bathtub and I forgot about that so
I'm gonna go get that
why does a dead body in the bathtub but
there is a dead body in the bathtub and
that is worthy and then hopefully at
some point we can get like I don't know
oh wait wait a minute I wasn't even done
exploring oh if the answer is here I'm
gonna be pissed I don't think you do
okay I don't they I'm not pissed the
answer is not here by the looks of it
but that doesn't mean that I'm not
pissed anyway I'm pissed off no matter
what way you spell it I'm pissed all
right whatever I got this here go up
here get over yonder way I'll come back
I'll come back to this I'm gonna go cut
someone's heart out and then I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna come back oh I got
this I got this Red Bull guy mark thank
you for everything I hope you keep
making everyone happy with your Let's
Plays and screams thank you for
everything I recently had head injury
and I'm slowly recovering thank you well
I hope you get better soon I'm really
sorry that you had a head injury are you
typing that from the hospital if so get
better soon we're all pulling for you
Aston Martin hey mark thank you for
being a big inspiration you mean being a
big old dummy who doesn't know what he's
doing half the time but I appreciate the
sentiment for us let's go cut somebody's
heart out hello nice dick there we go
and Bab Gabby laughs snip snap snip snip
II snippy all right ooh I got a human
heart yay
well maybe I don't need for mushrooms
maybe it was just like that's what I
needed
there's gotta be like there's got to be
some answer then I'm not getting here
right like I had to have had to be as
something in order to fill up the water
tank I need to redirect the water flow
to the prop room but I don't know maybe
the answer was actually in the prop room
because then I would have known like
maybe the pipes leading to their hello
maybe the pipes leading to there would
have been more informative how did I
even get to the proper him again holla
wait I just totally forgot how do I get
to the prop room how it though is it too
thick
it was through here right it was in the
main my brain guys my brain hurts real
bad guys my brain ah I was here that's
right - oh my god couldn't believe I
forgot that maybe maybe something's here
I mean I've got a lot of the ingredients
the only thing I don't have is the water
so let me check to make sure the waters
not already open because it's open I'm
not gonna try the number stop saying the
numbers their numbers are done we don't
into our numbers doing numbers we need
or more likes that's all the matters of
the world I don't even know numbers 1 2
3 4 5 I need oh [ __ ] I'm out that's the
only thing in matters stats shares are a
little Oh Oh fun fact apparently I have
no idea about this apparently see any
pipes or anything there was uh there's
one big pipe I asked someone of
streaming on twitch and I was asking
someone to go get a sound clip of me
saying and Schurz are a little low this
month and apparently I've never said
that in that old video I never said
shares are a little low this month I've
never said those workers which is
fascinating it's fascinating to me it's
fascinating
I never said actually the words shares
are a little low this month which is
just ridiculous
I could not believe anyway so I didn't
get the water so there's got to be some
answer to that but I haven't found it
yet so the one thing I might do is I'm
gonna go up to the laboratory and I'm
going to brew up the potion because I do
believe I have all the ingredients
necessary for that what are the numbers
mean I don't know Oh 3 2 1
3 plus 2 plus 1 equals 6 4 plus 5 equals
9 that's how you do 69 oh that's that's
funny that's funny right there that's
use a funny wound I like you used to
pulling me funny all right we got to
find where I was going I just don't
upstairs we need to go to the up I gots
to go up into the laboratory nope that's
down wait do I need to go up into the
laboratory or did I need to what sit
over here is in the the conservatory was
over here which is not where I need to
go I don't think so I don't think I need
to go to yeah I don't need to go to the
conservatory because that's where all
the plants were I need to go up these
stairs ease to some place up these
stairs ease which is somewhere where the
hell are you in that yeah yeah in the up
here
I'm here is it here I can't remember
anything
dude your voice is so freaking cool oh
thank you thank you which voice this is
this voice I bet it's that voice that's
pretty cool voice yay good dear I think
maybe not no this is where oh no this
was it okay love all rah rah
let's go brew us up some ectoplasm I
gotta scrape it off my skin if you
recall but I'm so bad I'm pretty sure I
don't think that they needed me to get
for mushes because if I need for mushes
like how how big is this trip gonna be
if I'm doing for mushes alright let's
squeeze this heart oh it really was
squeeze the heart you know I didn't
realize it was squeeze the heart guess
I'm oh I don't have like a charm
maybe the bucket bucket oh there forever
I don't have a jar I kind of forgot Oh
does the ectoplasm oh I have a jar okay
I have an active plasma okay I don't go
in there apparently
well how about you know all right how do
I let's see there not that one we're
getting closer though I feel like it's
right nope okay maybe I gotta put the
jar under here there we got it we got
there eventually guys we got there boys
and girls we got there we did it we did
oh that was a squish all right I got the
incomplete brew great hmm okay not there
put it in the conflab you later
no oh no object wait no the conflab you
later no I'm not the conflab you later
how about that nope okay well maybe we
put this in here yo the conflab you
later is engaged let's put this here the
oven is not full
I think I think um okay look not ready
to be blah what do you want from me it's
just three ingredients how did how did
Teddy sprinklin he'll how dope would are
you you're all right there's only so
many there's only so many things okay I
do need for Marsh's okay all right I get
it
I need for mushes I got it
all right I understand I don't know
where to get formal I don't know where
to get for mushes there was something
else - what in here like this was this
is locked is there something in here
that I don't like it when it's
something's locked like this you know
what I mean I don't like wearing there's
something locked so there's got to be
something to that
- right baby I don't know at this point
I'm just grasping at straws I've already
looked in these monopoly okay all right
I do need for mushes which makes me
believe that maybe there were four
mushes to be out in the conservatory and
I just didn't look hard enough maybe
that's the case and maybe I need to go
back no I mean where else with mushes be
than the conservatory right that's where
I found the first one
maybe the other ones were down there and
I just didn't see them all again
I need four mushrooms
I'll get there eventually there's the
problem I would normally cut all this
[ __ ] out maybe these lamps are secretly
mushes okay let me think about this
rationally
so I've got an incomplete brew the oven
is not full so I need three other
mushrooms the mussels were only from the
conservatory so logic would dictate
that's where I would go I went to the
underground area in the cellar you
divert the water by doing the pipes but
I don't have all the pipe stuff that I
need so probably thinking rationally
about this I probably need to go back
down to the conservatory and be extra
thorough about it
that's the only place that I could think
to go there's also more places to go
hate that I hate that every time I go by
there I hate that there's also more
places to go like the maze garden that
could potentially be a place where there
might be mushes but I'm gonna go to
where I went first before I go anywhere
else makes sense yeah it makes sense it
makes sense if you really don't think
about it too much
so there's gotta be ok this was this was
the way down there but was through here
uh toilet there definitely was no mush
here so there was a very specific reason
why it said mush one of four here that
bum bum lady is gonna tell me it wasn't
in the pits was it wait that's a month
that's a mush wait
that's a mush that's a mush wait okay
dad was a mush that was a mush okay so
that was a mush so the only way to get
down there is down through here right so
who's just on the ground
maybe I wasn't looking down that's my
problem I keep looking up at the sky
gate to wait what so I got to open it so
I got to open the gate somehow this is
real puzzle II and behind each gate is
gonna be another mush I get it now
I understand I see I know what's going
on here oh oh
how many of you guys saw that how many
of you guys saw that and I just blew
right by it
how many know so where's the way to lift
it
oh that's bad us so bad
okay so there's got to be some secret
way to raise the gate right I feel like
a giant turd oh now you're all just
saying you did to try to be like no I
knew that
you didn't know some of you knew but I
can't prove which one did and which one
didn't so I'm just gonna say you're all
liars
that's what I do that's it that kind of
person
okay so I don't think there'd be
anything up there like a secret book to
pull is we've back there again is there
another book that I gotta yank to get
the oh no that's just a book period okay
that flew off the shelf that's not a
pulley book there's just a book okay so
those weren't pulley books but I'm
thinking no that's candles too maybe
oh damn it I thought I funk old life
uncle drawn so how do I open this other
gate gate number two how do I open you
how do i I need to walk through I'm
gonna need to walk through eventually
but I don't even know if there would be
a written up walkthrough for this
open the gate - how do you do it I'm at
a complete loss I'm gonna lose my mind
how do you do it it's more loyal
how you do the up again - I just wanted
another mush honey open gate - how'd he
do it - break it down maybe something to
do with the toilet it's gotta be
something simple right
I haven't even seen anything that like
doesn't even give you like any detail
when you approach gate - was there
anything to this one not doesn't even
turn anymore there's a walkway up there
is there a way to get up to that walkway
that looks like a thing is that door
wait hang on there's a door up there
wait is there a way to get up to that
walkway uh-huh okay where does oh oh oh
my god wait I had oh don't wait if I
take the ladder
oh no the thing this the this you how do
i unstick you there's got to be uh this
is how do i unstuck it where's oil
I have oil for my lamp do you want blood
I could I could spare a little blood
there's a dis this is it how do i
unstuck it do I just got a Whangdoodle
it real hard
I got a barrel no maybe I just maybe I
just slam jam it
I just wham jam it
get one stalk kid there's gotta be
there's got to be something right where
have I seen something that can lube this
up there's got to be some kind of
lubricon hello baby do you have any idea
where they find Lube not trying to make
any assumptions about you but it's just
like uh-huh thought you might know where
Luba might be okay there's gotta be some
kind of think there's got to be some
kind of usable Lube somewhere it's gotta
be Lou somewhere Oh cut the rope that
Oh
I got cut the rope
huh thank you for that thank you
I fix are you guys can see that I'm
thinking really hard like I'm thinking
I'm thinking so hard but my brain can
only think so much my brain can only do
so much thinking one is Stuckey to
almost you guys can see right you can
see I try I try really hard it just
doesn't always work thank you everyone
that's sponsoring I appreciate that I
don't know what amazing sponsors yeah I
appreciate that maybe I'll start like a
sponsor group chat or something like
that I don't even know if I can do that
oh I forgot that this was a horror game
for a moment okay uh that's uh say
something I need to worry about like now
or they're just a worry later kind of
problem is okay that's a hidey hole that
uh I legitimately like completely forgot
this was a horror game I was so wrapped
up in my own problems like kind of all
right
it's really quiet for just hearing the
moans of the Damned over there okay mush
not what I need there's mush down here
well there's mush you know I I have the
worst feeling about this oh I'm not a
happy camper Oh
[Music]
yo ya'll eat we did it call them oh I
didn't know I didn't know you're real Oh
oh my god
[Music]
okay we're good we're good we're good
okay all right I think we're good yeah
back back back yeah yeah yeah yeah
I hated that yeah good it was so much
more disconcerting because it was so
quiet there's just silence
oh god okay well we got what we needed
wahoo
yeehaw Oh oh my god that was terrorist
Lee that bet scared the piss out of me I
was like I I played a lot of horror
games okay and there wasn't really
anything like special about that
sequence it was it was everything
leading up to the sequence that threw me
off right
it was misdirection it made me think
that I was safer than I really was
because I knew that something bad was
company coming I just didn't know it
like for certain I didn't know what it
was I didn't know like where it was
gonna pop up and and the fact that it
made me realize that thing was there the
whole time just slowly creeping up on me
it was terrifying
really well done that's really well done
and looks like it's understated like
horror should be understand a horror
isn't all about done sometimes sometimes
you just need like a quiet moment and a
lot of build-up to it and I can really
mean it you know the difference in the
world
are you okay anyway I'll stop I'll stop
sucking the developer's dick here
okay all right back to it back to me
complaining about how stupid I am
because I'm sure that I'm gonna
disappoint real soon but we got four
mushes we can get this in this bad boy
we can mix this all up and we can get it
done and then hopefully we can get some
sort of an answer about how we can um
how can we can get everything that we
need there's a lot of mush whoa all
righty then eager beaver there we go oh
yeah that looks like some goopy goop
that's really gonna go it well with my
my heart ectoplasm combo incomplete brew
time to boiler up no sorry okay all
right there we go let's gas it up oh
hell yeah it self-lighting love it
yeah boil all the blood off just leave
the ectoplasm that's all I need
[Music]
Thank You Tyler green the build-up is
crucial to any jump scare yeah not even
jump scares just scares in general jump
scares are do benefit from a build-up
that's like why the original 5 minutes
of Freddy's was very good because I
loved the moments when in the original
five nights at Freddy's if you have your
screen up and one of the things got in
it wouldn't come down until you put the
screen down but if you listened you
could hear them you knew they were there
and it's like death is there oh god no
and that can either build you up for it
if you just let yourself like get it too
much but it also is this it's a sense of
dread like that's what a lot of horror
games don't have is like a sense of
dread and that's what the first five
nights at freddy really had it had this
sense of dread to it like cuz I like
knowing no one ever played a game like
five nights at Freddy's before five
nights at Freddy's maven when it came
out it was late I'm just in one room cuz
he was the dread it was the dread of it
it was like the unsee mning nature of
these like animatronics that were so
nice friendly haha they were too
threatening originally but then it's
like oh [ __ ] we got the port of mortis
but I still don't know I still don't
know how to divert the water so
considering my lack of knowledge in
you're not close to being here
no she she's not really here is she
[Music]
No
see now that got me second guessing
myself because I'm like is she really
I don't know I don't know I need to go
to UM not there uh yeah wait there there
is this this way I think yeah this way I
need to go back down here because the
answer must be down here it's like it's
gotta be it you know you know yeah no no
she's just screaming to scream or maybe
she was I don't know that's the thing I
don't know I don't know I have no idea
okay but we're data back down the line
so there's got to be an answer to what
order the pipes going right it's gotta
be there was machine rooms there have to
be like some piece of paper somewhere
that tells me exactly what to do with
the Machine right by him that's the only
thing that makes sense and it probably
would be in one of those other machine
rooms down there either way let's just
go down let's be really meticulous about
this because I don't see any other place
to have the information to deal with the
waterworks then in the waterworks right
it's the only thing that makes sense
okay there's no ups there's these pipes
but these pipes don't really mean
anything
I don't think she's gonna be here still
their pipe still
all right
nothing area
I don't think the candles meaning I
don't think there's gonna be like any
environmentally hidden thing that's
gonna tell me the only thing that we see
here is machine parts I think that's
your anything actually up there it's our
way to get up there it's our book some
kind of moldy old book that has any
information about it
these three pipes that doesn't mean
anything I see nothing okay so there's
absolutely nothing in here
nothing of a pipe structure here here
there's nothing up here we've already
been down there back in the other area
I'll go back there if I can't get the
answer later
oh hey going back to your roots mark
yeah I I recently discovered that there
are tons and tons of really highly well
made and these your custom stories still
being made to this day I think that's
fascinating okay no paper there's
nothing it's just one two three four
five have I seen anything that pertains
to one two three four five has there
been any note that I picked up that
might have something do with one two
three four five
or just mortis no red nurse not Mr
Cameron's letter not three two one four
five is 69 I don't know if that's it
let's try it
nothing yeah the only way that I would
know is I bet if is if this pops up
because this is not Oh what what no no
that was open the whole time are you
kidding me
no I know
[Music]
Oh bad it's bad everyone called me a bad
call me a bad so bad oh no I'm so dumb I
tried it would look stuck what the hell
is this whoa what am i doing whoa
Oh what the hell is this I've never seen
this before what is this oh oh this is
cool I don't know what I'm doing with it
but I don't know why is here but whoa
okay
Oh is there some whoa I see
ahaha yeah okay we know hold hold there
okay so Pump Room I needed to go to the
prop room two three four okay
two three four two one three four the
conservatory I bet there's some Easter
Egg if you get it to go to the
conservatory two three four those are
the ones I need I can't even go over
there that's clever
wait but is that all of it is it just
two three four yeah I think it's just
two three four that's it no no no no no
you springy bastard that's cool I've
never seen anything like that was that
it maybe in like a machine for pigs but
does pretty cool all right two three
four two three four two three here close
the other ones got it two three and four
easy peasy god I still feel incredibly
stupid okay so I just gotta close the
ones that
open these two
to air that it was so simple oh oh that
was her Oh Oh No thank you oh I'm dead
I'm very dead oh no wait am i dead okay
I'm not dead
nevermind I'm fine I might be dead oh I
might be dead am I even going the right
way I don't even remember anymore where
am I going oh okay all right I'm gonna
assume I'm fine I'm gonna assume I'm
fine I'm just gonna assume I wish I
could turn behind me like an outlast
okay we're fine uh right we're fine okay
yay we did it whoo okay no don't call me
up call me a bad boy that's weird don't
do that don't do that that's weird
yeah go for if you wanted well Who am I
to tell you what to do Who am I
oh thanks for sponsoring Morganville
thank you so much I see Jess she has to
be right or maybe not okay
I need to go to the proper
she's here hate that hate that she's
getting real and she was getting real
antsy but I'm good good good I'm good
I'm good
she's getting real antsy real antsy well
we got this and I don't know if it's
gonna go into chapter 3 where it's gonna
be like some kind of conclusion here who
knows but at least we're gonna probably
get Sammy back maybe probably I don't
know we're gonna have to like make a
choice aren't we like choose to get our
get our baby bro back or you know either
way
time to jump into a water tank hey Tesla
you know why'd you have to go to the
paranormal
right prepositions are done it's time
for my astral travel yeah I just learned
about this today but I'm coming for you
Sammy Sammy Sammy boy Sammy ME ME boy
sploosh should I take it I didn't take
the potion though gods drown I guess
jump and forget to take the potion
you're just like flying in his dreams
was an exhilarating breathtaking
experience there is colors shown through
what he could only describe as the veil
of existence okay all right cool
very cool
[Music]
hello
oh I made it I guess
now where is here hello baby how you do
didn't expect oh hello baby how are you
doing okay didn't expect there to be
water here alright that is a gate where
am I
Sami Sami boy Sammy boy a little baby
Sammy boy oh I don't know if I trust
this but I'll go up I guess all right
fine
drowning equals teleportation yeah
absolutely all right well every bug more
than that haven't
hmm it's like the vision what's like the
vision Oh like the vision we had why I
keep am I not gonna be able to get out
of this am i really are you really just
gonna oh my god are you kidding me oh
all right there we go got it all right
how much oil we got we need to fill er
up not much okay very little oil okay
why is there machinery here what kind of
weird world is this whoa oh hello okay
window where am I wait this looks
familiar
I've seen something like this from like
the beginning of the machine for pigs or
something like that cuz warned that
maybe something seems a little bit
familiar here yeah oh yeah no no no the
ladder wasn't getting the best of me lie
I showed the ladder who was the boss and
it the boss just so happens to be me can
I get out oh [ __ ] I can Oh beautiful
Oh Chapter three
all right Sammy boy I'm coming for you I
drank a weird potion filled with shrooms
I'm coming to get you this is like
straight out of a machine for pigs I
think even like this level is like
straight out of the chute based on some
crazy it's been a while since I played
that game to be perfectly honest dad
it's been a while but it's kind of cool
oh I guess I'm going the right way then
oh he pooped we're to go now now don't
run from me come on now where's Sammy
boy who a great bird with
jack-o'-lanterns okay Sammy boy Sammy
boys a boy oh [ __ ] mental institution of
Bucharest hello baby
I hope you can hear me all the way up
there that's a weird grumble alright I'm
goin in alright yeah can I borrow this
thank you didn't need it for someone
alrighty then
okay hello anybody here is there
anything worth perusing in this desk
hello hello no okay I'm gonna go up the
stairs then guess each big place locked
okay well maybe not as big as I thought
it was gonna be because there's nothing
I can do no okay all right well this is
a mystery hmm once there's an open door
on the other side I have no idea nope
Oh winner winner let me see if this one
opens ooh nope they all locked maybe
there's something in here no I can't
even go in it and even go in it all
right hello that's a good whistling
sound that's real nice actually I'm up
whoa okay that actually a monster up
here or should I can I drop my guard
okay all right hold on whole lot happens
all right well way to go for me Oh God
like this again with the howling little
weird oh okay
I'm went up another level how did I even
go up another level there wasn't even a
staircase to another level
can I borrow this thank you no not that
one
hey Oh slam dunk excuse me nope I guess
I go down then weird this is a lot of
environment to just have me plowing
through it like top school Oh gross it
Wyatt it gross war word the orphan girl
giggled and looked up dude he was
smiling at her and warmed the long-held
Queen and her tiny chest come with me
he said in a gentle voice that's okay
all right all right I guess this is
Bucharest a gun okay why is our gun here
where's your gun under the desk
[Music]
oh boy what the flying [ __ ] was okay all
right
no no I don't think we need to run
that's fine I'm used to the whispers I'm
used to the last person here's another
one I bet this one's not gonna work - I
don't know why I'm even bothering yep
nothing a lot of nothing thank you for
the oil at least come on if you're gonna
do something just do something to jump
out and do some already huh the oil is
that all I came up here for is it really
all I came up here for
they can't have been the only thing no
come on now ethereal gate - key got it
okay great
let me check the drawers over here just
ball guys I ran out of oil oh it scared
the bejesus out of me
who's crying who's crying and why I'm
really on edge now and I don't wanna I
don't want to have to deal with anything
gimme outage get me through the gate
everything's gonna be fine oh hello good
children remember silence and hard work
are the roots roads to heaven of course
[Music]
okay all right good Tunes good jams
great for children to listen to you
alright I guess nothing oh wait over
here okay oh oh why didn't I in the
fight I didn't know I did not know I did
not know I did not know I did not know
you coming here seem a little slow whoa
boy whoa that's one of the suitors from
the Justine expansion but looks
different Olli you don't like that okay
I'm gonna you don't seem that fast who
seems faster now
Oh probably very fast oh good that's a
problem
oh I hate that yeah no no no no no no no
[Applause]
okay do they get away okay all right
okay all right bottom like you like oh
good okay young heart a vessel of life
emptied and paled okay I'm glad these
children are just drawing pentagrams in
their bedrooms that's that's real
productive usually their time wait
didn't like somewhere else wait did I
just move somewhere else did I I did
what the hell where am I now
Oh big ol hole in the ground that's oh I
gotta go down there okay all right well
before I do let me check this door no
blocked him won't open without a key did
I somehow just get around it is that
what I did all right let's go down ha No
okay didn't hurt at all
I've been building on my legs with
repeated impacts when you break your
legs a few times they do heal back just
a little bit stronger than they did in
the past
excuse me two points three points all
right
okay well what am I looking at what am I
looking at what am I looking at what am
I seeing what do I see what is that well
it's a table okay nevermind sorry
thought it was something incredible he
was a table thought it was like a pile
of corpses but it was a table it turns
out it's just a table that's bread on
table alright you don't get up how about
this big here you go buddy I know you're
hungry Oh got you something oh that's
not where you should stick your nose
biggie but ok Who am I to tell you what
to do
ok why did I come in here oh the key
that's right okay probably opens the
door somewhere in this area I think I
know don't don't don't don't don't don't
do not don't don't don't don't don't
don't no no no no no no no no only only
way out is up oh no no no no
no no no oh no oh no oh no oh no this is
no higher Oh No huh
no one higher one more please just Oh
once couch or scoochie Gooch one Gooch
Gooch when when little touchy scoochie
higher one who talk huh no one little
itty-bitty coochie coochie higher one
the dooty is dooty Astari
that's the good stuff that's the truth
get up up up
[Music]
alright well that one well really happy
about that I still have the key huh I
don't even have to go back down there
anymore won't even let me haha I failed
it let's just assume that I nailed that
good I don't good oh my god
well I failed that challenge but you
know I think I wanted in the hearts of
the people that's really what matters
he's done open everyone please just
pretend like I nailed that just please
just give me some false encouragement be
like the like button don't have any
actual effect on things but you make me
feel better just like make me feel good
here just lie tell me sweet lies lie to
me boy oh I'm on the other side of the
gate that's good oh hi buddy
several of the patients breach their
containment area last wait no no this
one several of the patients breach their
containment area last night this results
being the worst ride in the history of
this institution the aggressors have
been transferred to the catacombs below
those tunnels now serve as tombs for the
subjects of failed treatments the abode
a of callous ghosts of madness madness
okay alright thank you for dealing with
me I've got two magical buttons and I'm
gonna use the [ __ ] out of them you best
believe that okay please
thank you nothing no point in that all
right oh wait a minute
hello hello hello nothing no point in
that okay let's keep rolling Oh No let's
see if No okay only way let's do it I
bravely went here the first time around
no no
fascinating hmm they're hiding some in
here that I know they're hiding goodies
back here what are they hiding what are
you hiding
are they not hiding any actual goodies
good all just a trick that's just a
trick there's nothing here or I'm going
in the elevator
Burnley red or green okay I guess we're
green then no matter what I wanted
[Music]
they're adding drugs what are they
hiding exactly exactly right it just
makes you question like what are they
what are you trying to deal with I know
it's some I don't some I'm too smart I'm
too smart for them to pull over the wool
of my eyes oh wait what what what what
they pulled the wool over my eyes they
pulled it right over them my eyes
they're full of wool we didn't go
anywhere oh you dick
we didn't go nowhere are you kidding me
are you digging with me oh that's that
that is that's problem
Oh
I don't like this
hello how are you you good are you oh I
get it I was just supposed to push the
button to bunch it's like a elevator
from hell I get it okay thank you
that made my heart jump that made my
heart jump that was a hearty jump that's
why it didn't go anywhere it sounded
like it went and didn't go anywhere
[Music]
that's good that's that I got it that's
kind of clever that's kind of clever
kind of clever
it's me
nothing here let's see what it does
again let's iterate let's iterate this
baldon yeah they pulled the wall right
into my eyes out of my eyes are a round
to my eyes through my eyes they I
everything hello oh yeah how about no my
first instinct was to press the button
might that was my first instinct but
they should have liked her charge in you
that would have made me hit it real fast
what do we got next what kind of horror
shower we gotta see gram no I don't like
this now I get it now I get it
now I
our past our best our best Hardcastle
our best
no smash nose match there's a bad game
as fast pass pass pass
hard pass pass
it's not what I like I'm a bit okay all
right
she cried and struggled as he pulled on
her arm to have no idea what fate
awaited her behind that cellar door nor
did he but he felt a strong sense of
foreboding pass empty all right I'll try
whoa hey I buddy I've been startled by
you before but not this time okay that's
a whole lot of nothing okay all right
well I guess I guess I'll go right then
hello hello okay never mind that was a
big door anyway hey how's it going buddy
please don't pull again oh what a mess
I've got a chair hey ya know you miss me
[ __ ] that's what you get you think you
can mess with the likes of me the answer
oh [ __ ] that old battle-ax or that open
I wanted to go to that one okay
that one did not open dude they are
coming indeed they are they are they are
in fact there are coming let's take I
think he'll be fine though I don't know
if I'm supposed to pull the maneuver
that I pulled yeah he's there though my
chairs gone so I guess I can't pull that
maneuver anyway but uh whatever I'm
supposed to do I honestly have no idea
is he just gonna come around the girl I
guess I can lose him around the eagle
statue if he comes all the way out of
here I can lose him around the eagle
statue that's definitely okay he's
coming all the way over no he stopped
nope he's coming he's coming okay
[Music]
okay again I don't know if he's gonna
come on around here but this is what the
only thing I can imagine because there's
no way that I can outrun them they're
actually faster than me I could try to
dodge their blows but that doesn't mean
I'm gonna outrun them okay come this way
come my dears away a bigger boy there he
is
that's a big boy that's a big boy all
right come all the way out here all the
way keep going
no keep no why did I run don't kill me
I'm gonna jump over this you're never
gonna get me hop sick maneuvers I don't
know why did I run why well I didn't
have to run why did I run why did I run
why I didn't have to didn't have to run
I do not there's no need to run there
was no need to run there's no need oh
there was so much not needed maybe I can
hide behind a toes they'll never find me
he's gonna walk right by this is gonna
work out perfectly trust me trust me
when I say he's gonna go ride by me he's
gonna blast right by me not even see me
no way oh yeah and I got this I got this
yeah I got this you got this are you
ready already hold on yeah this I know I
know what to do you guys think I don't
know what I got it okay it's all gonna
take I can't pick those up ah [ __ ] I
thought I could pick up the potatoes
[ __ ] whatever all right I'll be patient
all through the waiting thing fine
whatever but I'm gonna wait around this
pillar that's what I do cuz that way I
can get closer to where I need to go and
dad will be by a door I should also have
like a brick that I can throw or
something is there any object I can like
throw maybe
nah nothing okay I just gotta wait for
him just gonna wait like a good patient
person like someone who's patient how
are you guys doing you good you good
I got killed so hard I'd died to death
yeah that's pretty pretty pretty much
pretty much accurate ruined it I hope
this is enough to hide me it's gonna be
a knife it's gonna get it it'll be us
it'll probably be enough yeah yeah easy
as that easy as that and for Maori
Don Danzo dun dun Yin rings done easy
Don's it did it Don's it do it Dorn's it
I've done elated it did he
dick I've door with it I'd loved it
I filmed it didn't this one open no I
was lying myself while I cooked it I
glork tit i really-really gleek tit woof
i smooshed it i got it so good i got
that all right where the hell are we
gave me some oil goddamnit
oh boy another puzzle so this time I'm
not gonna be an idiot and I look for the
solution before Oh it's during package
delivery a day that you distinguish the
good from the truly rotten hang on wait
this time I found a carefully hidden
needle in one of the packages a wasted
attempt since there are no padlocks to
pick all the cell's of highly
sophisticated locking mechanisms powered
by steam as this was a requirement from
local authorities the last thing they
want is these deplorable roam in the
streets
it truly disappoints me when the
treacherous act such as this is
committed the ungratefulness is
unparalleled I put the needle back into
the package
maybe false hope is there a punished man
okay so there's a needle in someone's
package I guess all right I don't know
what to do with that information but
apparently these just go to the cells
then so if I do these it'll unlock all
the cell's now what I'm getting out of
this
[Music]
Oh only one can be
well that's tedious okay let me try
number six first because I had not I
think that's someone closest to me that
might be the one closest to me okay so
he's doing his wha why would you do that
what why why is he still there why is he
there
why is he there he shouldn't be there he
should go
no no wha oh why why why is why is he
doing this why is he doing this to me
well what this is not haughty bliss no
no no no no do not don't
don't
Oh kill it spotted some oil Oh golly gee
don't good okay so he is this gonna be a
son of a [ __ ] - this whole time so I'm
gonna have to meticulously go through
each cell to get a needle to go through
that padlock just go okay so I need a
needle this is number six
okay this is number six okay does work
like that so there's a needle in one of
these guys things it's not number six
doesn't look like it I don't see
anything here it does not look like it
I'm being thorough okay so number six is
a no no no go on number six so I'm just
gonna go down the list cuz that's what I
got to do and that's what I'm gonna do
so I got I do it I got to do right
number five
[Music]
he wouldn't have made his way back
around yet so it's got to still be over
my guess is that it's gonna be a son of
a [ __ ] and is gonna put the uh it's
gonna put it way whoa I don't know what
I did bed but that is funky okay not in
here I bet it's gonna be in like number
one or something I bet it's gonna be all
the way over but I'm still gonna go
procedurally still gonna go procedurally
that's all I know to do please don't be
all the way around yet please please
okay cool I did it I got it I could have
used the knife I guess long okay I'm out
of here
I'm Audi I'm Audi baby I'm Audi got it
we're doing this I think we're
approaching the end if I just add it
like my my inner knowledge of like how
these things usually go we got to be
getting close
bunk hello run everybody in there oh
nice wheel can I spin this there's no
point in me spinning that it's um one of
these ooh one of these no oil
god damn it oh god the timing of that
always throws yeah I'm not doing so good
oh well apparently there was no reason
to go in there that's bizarre
why would there be no reason go into all
those places yeah it's getting goopy
whoa
alrighty then okay
well we got another light here but I
don't know if I'm actually supposed to
do anything with this other than just
being here for an interrogation chair
that's weird
maybe these are just like showcases
maybe there's nothing actually important
in these I don't know why but we seem to
be descending into the lower levels of
madness here you know as far as astral
projection goes oh not breast not
impress seems to be horrible seems to be
just be a whole lot of horrible all
wrapped into one a dentist yeah there's
a dentist here in purgatory that that
makes that makes complete sense I would
believe that yeah absolutely
don't [ __ ] this up I'm trying not to I
keep doing it no matter what I do like
no matter what I just keep [ __ ] it up
Oh Katie you tweeted me the video of me
singing shares we're a little low this
month did I maybe it was just a
different vlog that someone went back
and saw but maybe there was one what
I okay I guess this is just a dead end I
thought they were gonna do something
about that dead end I thought it was
gonna you know be bad for me but
apparently not okay where am I now
oh yeah the nightmare goes on forever
absolutely forever
oh no I'm hurt now I'm whimpering like a
little [ __ ] baby you can't run from me
got you [ __ ] let's do this whoa well I
found the fun room boo-ki oh I didn't
mean to peekaboo okay oh boy my my sac
mommy my sacrifice okay okay all right
I didn't knows me that was sacrificing
something I thought it was Sammy boy I
mean I probably should be the one to
volunteer to be sacrificed if there's
gonna be any sacrifice happening oh
that's what this what she's black she
sound was this red nurse I've heard so
much about well you should have said so
from the gay you mind if I dip my
Tootsie's in all true she uh I was like
a good refreshing dip in the bow
I'd love to shower you have set up here
it's real nice anyway or I gotta get
back to saving Sam the boy alright you
know how it is you know how it is oh
nice smiley face okay mausoleum
mausoleum it is the sight of her
lifeless body crippled is his psyche her
eyes had been gouged out in her body
drained of essence he fell to his knees
and cried trying his hardest not to
indulge in self-pity but he could not
okay
justice Odin mark out of curiosity what
are your thoughts on the letter e oh you
know good pretty good pretty good
it was not bad not too shabby whoa okay
all right um I'm weird to happen in here
I mean look around the room before I go
up to the big thing I thought okay let's
do this lots of dudas hello oh it's a
casket little baby you all want to care
to explain
okay no explain necessary I'll just uh
whoa oh hi sir how you doing oh hey
how's it going are you how you guys
doing well do I have somebody nope okay
all right well
Oh Dell what did what why is this
grabbable why is it what the hell what
why my hand
why can I touch that why can't I touch
it I'm gonna throw a bone at it hello no
all right look I'm
did something
to help
it did something something happened
what the hell is happening
what's going to wait
do I need to stab these and get some
more hearts Oh gonna borrow something
shale but no ya borrow some excuse me
boink nope okay how can I touch these
I'm good good
cut the oh god damn it
cut the silver oh the thing that's been
talking about this all [ __ ] game
the thing has been target about the
whole game I'm I look at this shining
light and I'm like what's this long
thread light shining silver thing I
don't know I don't draw at all holy baby
boo boo can you look oh hey Sammy boy
oh you're Sammy Santa Santa Santa Santa
boy
[Applause]
that is that good or bad
I'm gonna run towards the evil light I'm
gonna go do all that maybe I'll run away
maybe that's maybe the red light bat
maybe maybe maybe just maybe the red
lights back um oh let's see here um oh
nothing ah ah here we go here there we
are
not too shabby not too shabby she's
probably right behind me but that's
alright I'll make a left through I was
the wrong direction oh you still there
okay I don't know what I'm doing I don't
know where I'm going but I'm going for a
swim
okay splishy-splashy
left-right
o Umba
ball Badou oh here we go Looby do okay
here we go oh okay that answers that
question
I think I'm running away from someone
but I can't quite tell
oh please Oh Oh bad oh good good crank
I got a crank I can put this on the
Tahoe that was the Gorby oh no that hurt
if you please tell me you haven't broken
through that already because I all that
was breaking through the CD or we're
back
what huh I got I got turned around no
that's not good that's probably bad okay
all right one more cranky Yankee a we
outie Wow D here we go
okay I'm out I'm out baby here we go oh
that's not good oh come on I'm miss
moans a lot over there oh you got your
thread cut no no okay I'm going we're
here I'm gonna take the lighted path I
guess
I guess I guess I'm just trying to get
back right
that's all I think I'd be doing well
probably shouldn't you take the time to
do this I just jump off Wow
okay maybe breaking my leg wasn't such a
good idea
oh that's probably bad that sounds great
oh that's good pretty bad that's pretty
bad I can't see Shaw vessel of life of
essence trained empty and paled Lambie
I couldn't see anything because this was
completely empty but we try that again
I'm guessing I probably shouldn't break
my legs
[Music]
I like our chat can't decide to whether
to press F or press e I'd like to think
I'm the only channel that has that
conundrum with their fan base now here
we go
I guess I don't know if it's gonna go
any better for me maybe I'm a little
faster
can't quite tell still sounds bad
still sounds real bad okay what have
gotten out here
there we go okay yeah
that's bad Scottie
[Music]
fief that's like like wracked with
indecision
Oh Sammy boy Oh stupid to do busy
laughing at fief for you guys to realize
that Sammy boy was walking back faith oh
that was great meant a lot of fun
without that I had a lot of fun with
that what really made that one special
is it just wasn't all about like it
wasn't all about constant jump scares it
was about building this environment it
was building a world he was telling a
story it was a little too wordy
admittedly from the notes I feel like a
lot of the story could have been told
you know like in the originally amnesia
when you're walking it kind of speaks
you as you're walking so that you get to
look in the environment ants and hear it
I feel like a lot of this story could
have been told through that instead of
just notes but still was good I am doing
it greatly I'm glad that you guys were
here food
chatez chats gonna you guys are gonna be
busy for a bit but nonetheless thank you
guys so much for joining on this one
this was a nice long one I was hoping
for a long one and I was open AB some
fun with it and and we really did we got
stuck a few times but what else is new
you know back when I was doing Emily's a
long time ago I never actually uh I
never actually cut anything out so that
was it so this was cool so thank you
everybody so much for joining me
fief strong and prosper thank you so
much for I have no idea was even I can't
even read anything besides a FIFA
so thank you thank you everybody so much
for joining me on this one I hope you
guys liked it thank you everybody so
much that gave through super chat thank
you everybody so much they're signing up
for sponsorships I'm probably gonna
think of something cool for sponsorships
at some point in the future
also remember we're going to tour if you
haven't gotten a ticket and you're in
Australia or New Zealand check out
toward market Blair comm get a ticket
for yourself if you enjoyed this let me
know in the comments well I guess the
comments is right here so press the like
button if you want to see more cool
stuff like this or just more live
streams in general or you just want to
show your support in any way shape or
form subscribe for more cool videos that
come along and my upload schedule has
been kind of [ __ ] lately so I usually
joke about the bail but if you do want
notifications I don't know when I'm
gonna be uploading for the next few days
because I'm still gonna be writing like
a madman so turn on notifications if
you'd like to see that otherwise I will
see you soon thank you everybody so much
for watching a lot more cool videos for
you tomorrow
so thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye bye guys
thief press press f2 fief bye